today
the supreme court
overturned roe and casey
we expected this to happen and i believe
this is the biggest story of our
generation and i don't know if i can
speak for gen x's or or boomers or
whatever for me this is
massive it's the biggest story and um
there's there's threats of violence dhs
is issued warning to churches people are
already protesting and i think on top of
this is that the text from clarence
thomas in his concurrence opens the door
to overturning gay marriage and whatever
else that might mean
there's a lot to talk about because we
also have a bunch of gun control issues
too because we just had that ruling and
now the states are reacting as well so
we're going to get into this before we
get started head over to timcast.com and
become a member to support the very
important work we do as a member you get
access to our exclusive segments from
this show monday through thursday at 11
pm and you'll be supporting our
journalists who have been covering these
stories all day sitting there making
sure to get the news out with the best
facts the the only only the best facts
the correct ones
and you'll also be supporting our
infrastructure we use rumble so that we
can be more resilient to censorship
without further ado joining us to
discuss all of this is austin peterson
hey thanks for having me guys um you
might know me from 2016. i ran for
president uh against gary johnson in the
libertarian primary famous for saying
that you shouldn't be able to sell
heroin to five-year-olds
and you know kind of being a guy who
pushed the issue of you know baking the
cake you know right the whole question
of you know should you be forced as a
christian to bake a wedding cake for a
gay couple
and that issue has come around you know
full circle in many other ways in
american politics now uh these days i'm
at a radio show and i also am a small
business owner i run the ap for liberty
shop.com website and um you know doing
entrepreneurial stuff trying to advance
liberty and basically being at the
forefront of missouri politics these
days uh trying to advance gun bills
there and advanced pro-life legislation
there and you know being a freedom
fighter in general i guess right on and
uh so we originally did not have will
chamberlain booked but this morning when
when the decision came down i'm reading
i'm reading some of these opinions i'm
like will can you come on because we're
gonna need a lawyer for this one yep
always good to be back will chamberlain
senior counsel at the internet
accountability project which fights big
tech abuses and the article 3 project
which fought to get trump's justices
confirmed
um
and so we're pretty happy about that
work um today so right on cool cool cool
so we'll need your legal perspective we
also got ian everybody dudes ian
crossland.net coming at you seamus you
look kind of happy today why do you say
that
is it because this is one of the
greatest days in american history
is that why i seem happy why aren't you
we're all laughing together this is
fantastic we're all laughing together
24. one thing for you to do now is make
a wish okay
what did you wish for i tell you won't
come true buddy
i'm just kidding i'm not superstitious
i've not been wishing i have been
praying along with many of you and we
still have work to do but this is
incredible this is a good friend so what
did you wish for i i
i don't i don't like wish all right i
like pray but also i would like
i
am praying for abortion to be illegal
nationwide
mike pence issued a similar statement
we'll we'll talk all about it he had a
cake too he did no no but uh for those
that are just listening they're probably
like why is everyone laughing it's
because sheamus has a cake which he's
cutting that says end of row
with the numbers 6-2-4
and and he blew the candles out made a
wish look i know he's cutting the cake
political victories in general are rare
victories of this magnitude are once in
a lifetime or can be once in a lifetime
we're going to make sure it's not once
in a lifetime though folks we're going
to fight for abortion to be illegal at
the federal level but today yeah i'm
gonna celebrate eat your cake we also
got lydia i am here in the corner it is
a great day for me as well you guys all
know that i'm super freaking pro-life
and i tweeted today guns check abortion
x that is the america i'm going for i'm
feeling really good as well i know we
have more to do just let me celebrate it
today looking forward to it all right
let's jump into the first store we got
here from timcast.com
everybody knows by now that roe v wade
has been overturned as well as casey
and uh in concurrence clarence thomas
wrote basically opening the door to
overturning gay marriage the text of
scotus roe vua decision opens door to up
and gay marriage justice thomas calls
gay marriage precedence demonstrably
erroneous
saying in future cases we should
reconsider all of this court's
substantive due process precedence
including griswold lawrence and
obergefell meaning those rulings are not
guaranteed to escape future judicial
scrutiny i'm going to stop right there
and ask will
break this down for us because some
reports were saying no no no this has no
bearing whatsoever on gay marriage
but it certainly sounds like clarence
thomas was like man we should we should
overturn those those wrongs so those
those reports are correct ultimately
like the underlying decision here in
dobbs does not actually implicate
necessarily other substantive due
process precedence so what is
substantive due process so think about
what is the due process guarantee right
it's you have the you know you know the
government can't take away your life
liberty of property without due process
of law and so most people would
understand that to mean oh due process
like procedural protections like they
can't take away my property without a
hearing and notice telling that they're
going to do it and the chance to appeal
things like that so that's
that's what most people think of when
they think of due process however the
court in order to protect certain rights
that they felt were so
essential that no process would be
sufficient to justify
your the government depriving you of
them they came up with this kind of
substantive due process doctrine that
was used to essentially create new
effectively create new rights um and
that doctrine has been used to protect
the right to use contraception um the
right to marry the person of your choice
etc now so then the question is okay
well row was also based on this
substantive due process idea does
overturning row mean all substantive due
process is dead
the answer to that is no
basically if you read dobbs they didn't
oh they didn't say substantive due
process was wrong in the majority
opinion they said here's how you
interpret substantive due process and
it's basically like is there a really
robust historical justification or
tradition of having this right even if
it wasn't spelled with the constitution
and they said that for abortion that's
not true they're just historically
abortion was routinely banned throughout
the states so there's not like a
historical backing for it but and but
throughout the dobs opinion they're
basically saying this doesn't
necessarily implicate any of the other
substantive due process rights those
have to go through the same analysis
we're not getting rid of substantive
duty process entirely
but it sounds like clarence thomas
clarence thomas would want to but his
views are pretty idiosyncratic on this
point
among the justices like i actually as a
legal matter i i kind of agree with
clarence thomas in the sense that i
think sub to to process as a doctrine is
incoherent nonsense but a bad person i
know but that that said like
you know i don't think you know if you
had a court case to try and overturn
obergefell on the grounds that
substantive due process is should
incoherent and you would i think that
that would lose 8-1 can i ask about the
what about interracial marriages how was
that decided how was the inter racial
marriage question decided in that same
sense so i think i think interracial
marriage and again i i'm i'm have to
reach back because i haven't read loving
versus virginia which is the relevant
case in a while but i think that's an
equal protection case and that's that's
a distinct doctrine right so kind of you
know substantive due processes some
rights are so important they cannot be
deprived of you no matter what equal
protection is people must be treated the
same way right you you can't you know if
if there is an existing right you can't
deprive it arbitrarily to one subset of
isn't that the argument in obergefell um
so i think obergefell is like this weird
mishmash
of both substantive due process and uh
equal protection because anthony kennedy
is not as was not maybe rest in p or no
he's still alive
and he just he just retired anthony
kennedy was a shout out
sorry he's still alive wrote a bunch of
really terrible like decisions from a
legal perspective i mean it's not even
like outcome i don't care he was more
conservative than not but just reading
his opinions was like reading a bad
writer like somebody who just wasn't
very smart and so you read his opinions
and they don't make sense well and so
oregonville was written by kennedy and
so it's not doc trying to leak
precise i think we're going to need a
supreme court ruling legalizing cloning
so that we can clone clarence thomas and
then nominate him eight more times but
the holy we got it we got a court we
gotta clone joe biden a bunch of times
too to try to keep stopping him from
getting out of the supreme court
yeah that's great and just berate him
you know from from a logic perspective
i'm reading clarence thomas and i'm like
what are you saying makes total sense
and then
i'm reading the the dissents i'm just
like on the gun issue and here i'm like
they have no idea what they're talking
about do they well i'm glad you're weird
i'm glad you're making an effort to read
from more people of color
so do we owe ruth bader ginsburg a debt
of gratitude
do we say thank you rbg you know what's
even more painful we might owe mitch
mcconnell
to be completely honest yeah he did
pretty good where it's due he didn't
just get the three you know the three
trump justices confirmed he also stopped
merrick garland
well let's
before i sit here and laugh and agree
with james on this one i'd actually
sheamus i know you you have a cake
you're celebrating this will you are you
you're uh are you happy to see ro
overturned yeah i mean i mean i think
we've talked about this before like i
would consider myself like like modestly
pro-choice right i think that we've
talked about this i think you and i
agreed basically on that right but so
you're both wrong
right as a you know i i also come at
this from a lawyer row was a literal
abortion of a decision
it's it's an absorption of legal
reasoning
i don't like that
so i'm more with sheamus on this one and
i consider myself a pro-life libertarian
and i think that you know all humans who
deserve the same equal protections equal
rights equal liberty and that the unborn
should be protected in the womb and
that's because libertarians believe in
personal responsibility number one so
elective abortions or heinous like we
were talking about before the show but
you know but even in the question of
rape i mean you have to ask yourself you
know what percentage of people that are
alive today are
the result of rape how many of those
people are glad they're alive how many
of those people
would say i'm so thankful to be here and
that i'm glad that they decided to adopt
my little sister for example
and i hope she doesn't mind that i talk
about this but it's kind of an open
family thing she's adopted
my parents and
her family
they had to have a conversation to try
and get her this
that mothered and not to kill her
and then they said please don't do that
and then once she was born the mother
didn't want her gave her to the
babysitter
and um
you know i remember being a young man 10
years old seeing my little sister for
the first time
five months old looking up in the most
beautiful brown eyes and saying to
myself i'm so thankful that she's alive
and that she's here and now i have a
little sister and i have a nephew mario
shout out to mario i love you so much by
the way um he's an awesome nephew a
great kid and my family is more full and
complete because without adoption
and you know are we talking about
adoption we need to be talking about
adoption more we need to be making
adoption more easy legally it's very
difficult to do it it's almost like
buying a baby these days you've got to
be rich to go and buy a baby
but we should be talking about that we
should be protecting life we should look
at life as a consistent ethic and i
believe in a consistent pro-life ethic
not because i'm religious because i'm
not
but because i do believe that all humans
deserve the same individual natural
rights and they should be protected from
reasonable idea of conception until
uh natural death so ian
as uh i don't think you're as
politically active as anyone else here
i'm curious are you happy to see roe v
wade over to well i got mixed feelings
um it's not making abortion illegal and
i think that's something people got to
realize it's just giving the states the
ability to choose i think that less
abortion is a good thing i don't know if
making it illegal is going to make less
abortion it probably will in the long
run and i think late term abortions are
absolutely gruesome um yeah they're
barbaric i mean you're you're a
full-grown human at like four months or
five months that's like a small human
being at five months yeah you see it
it's like
living and moving and all that stuff
but i i don't know i wasn't exp i was
expecting it once it leaked
i i still got mixed feelings i want to
talk about the the legal implications of
this because i want to know more and
obviously lydia is celebrating along
with sheamus i am over the moon about
this and i think one of the things that
i think people need to argue when they
talk about how uh the conservative
christians don't care about babies once
they're born that's an out and out lie
you know those pregnancy centers that
they're firebombing right now
those are the christian churches
response to abortion those help mothers
in need they help people who need the
kind of help they give free ultrasounds
they give free clothing they give
diapers they give bottles they have
shoes they teach parents how to parent
they have a response it's a very real
response so don't take any of that
argument from them they're full of
nonsense my my position is is you know i
sense before the show rather
dispassionate um you know i grew up i
think i you know will and i agree on
like a moderate kind of pro-choice but
it doesn't exist anymore in modern
politics it is basically the left is
pro-abortion they're they're they're
being asked about late-term abortion and
the response from prominent democrats is
it's the woman's choice and i'm kind of
just like my attitude is
if the woman hasn't has a health issue
and the baby can't like she can't carry
the baby anymore but the baby is viable
meaning it can live outside the womb why
kill the baby and there's no legitimate
answer that i've received because i
don't think there is a legitimate answer
it's completely dismissive of the idea
that the state might have an interest in
the life of an unborn child yeah which
is an absurd position yeah so i'll i'll
say this one more thing too considering
how insane everything's got in this
country i don't know if this is good or
bad in terms of the rising conflict but
i'd imagine it's probably it's probably
better
that the states can enforce their own
laws i feel like it may result in more
geographic hyperpolarization which could
be a bad thing probably is a bad thing
in terms of keeping this country
together but i'm also concerned about
the idea that
for too long you've had people who live
very different lives and very different
worlds are legislating for people who
live in in in different ways and and
this mostly is a view based on guns
because people in cities are like guns
should all be banned and then it's like
bro we had a bear on our porch a couple
months ago
i'm sorry dude you're not taking my guns
away and and aside from that's like i
know it's not an issue of hunting or
it's an issue of my right to defend
myself the people who live in cities
sure i get it you're not worried about
bears i'm all but you should be worried
about murderers and criminals because
crime is skyrocketing so look
the people who live in cities should not
be passing laws that directly
change the way of life for people who
live totally different lives and then i
see bells like this and i'm like it's
probably better off this way yeah i'm
not super positive but so there's a
couple things i really want to say about
this you're mentioning civil unrest the
fact that this country's so polarized i
agree that there's a chance this is
going to increase polarization almost
certainly will but i don't believe that
unity can or ever should come at the
expense of goodness beauty or truth i
believe that there are some things you
can't compromise on
i'll also say this
what the supreme court decided today was
not simply that states are allowed to
extend protection to the lives of unborn
children
they decided that the thugs and
terrorists who are mobbing outside of
the homes of supreme court justices
attempting to assassinate them and
kidnap their families and firebombing
pro-life charities do not get to decide
what law is in this country that is a
massive win for rule of law and not as
many people are talking about that we'll
explain that a little bit because every
single other institution for the past
several years has been caving into the
mob on everything there was no serious
condemnation from any of our political
institutions are the corporate world
over the blm riots or the 529
insurrection as we like to call it here
that's right there was absolutely no
condemnation of it no one was punished
for it they got away with it and in fact
their goals were forwarded because of it
they mocked the final president
and they mocked the president when he
was forced into a bunker because rioters
outside of the white house had breached
through the barriers after assaulting a
hundred and fifty federal agents and
setting fire to a church yeah
and the respect from the media was how
mean of it was donald trump to disperse
through those riders to go over the
church to have a photo shoot
how dare he and peaceful people a
peaceful protest and so what we are
seeing here is the and i think we really
need to pay attention to this it is the
first time in the last several years
that any of our major institutions has
stood up for itself and said no we're
not going to let violent thugs tell us
how to run our country let's jump to
this next story from timcast.com
democrats call supreme court
illegitimate
urge resistance following abortion
decisions
this is uh this is a story uh from
adrian norman from tim cast rep maxine
waters told protesters to hell with the
supreme court we will defy them aoc was
yelling illegitimate and um
i should say urging resistance
you mean urging insurrection and
violence now as much as i will jokingly
say urging insurrection and i'm making a
point by saying it i do appreciate that
at timecast.com we don't use that loaded
language but um the point i'm making
when i say insurrection is these
democrats are coming out right now and
and saying no to the supreme court and
more importantly and maybe you can
comment on this more uh will
the doj garland came out and rebuked
both the gun decision and roe v wade
when does the doj do that it it doesn't
that's not its job right the doj has it
ever come out and announced it would
defy or resist never seen in doj
independently make announcements and
pronounce on like how you know that it
how much it disagreed with the supreme
court decision like that's that's new to
me maybe maybe i'm wrong but i don't
recall the trump doj under bar ever
doing anything like this
um and i think that's because that's the
role i mean it's it's supposed to it
it's there's two big reasons one is that
the doj is supposed to have this nominal
appearance of independence right like
they're the enforcers of the laws um the
people who make the decision about who
to prosecute who not to prosecute so
like their them at least trying to
appear unbiased should be important
which is clearly they're just not and
then secondly you know they go in front
of the supreme court regularly i mean
the the us government is routinely a
litigant in front of the supreme court
defending its own laws
uh you know trying to also as amicus
likes making statements about other
cases that might implicate a federal
interest so
there's an importance for the doj itself
to have a somewhat like good you know
working relationship with the courts in
fact like the solicitor general is often
called like the 10th justice because
they're supposed they're so often in
front of the court and the idea that doj
would jeopardize that by just going you
know the attorney general being like
you're all wrong and you're idiots like
okay dude i mean that's
that could that actually breaking that
relationship and maybe it's good because
you want the government to lose in the
supreme court a lot but it's it's very
unique and bizarre well i thought
what you just said there yeah i'm
putting more rights
i'm not going to stop celebrating it's
hard but you made this point you're
saying that it's uh it could be great if
the supreme court just starts siding
against the government more often in my
mind that's fantastic yeah like i'm
gonna make another cake no here's i
gotta run out of cases i've got a
question for everybody slippery slope
right so when we were younger they would
say well people would say well if you
allow gay marriage then they're going to
start trying to groom your kids and if
you start to wait they're doing this
yeah
all everything the christian rights said
just turned out to be true
so does so my question is is the
slippery slope not a fallacy right if
you look at abortion they said if you
allow abortion they're going to say well
now it's no longer just safe legal you
know rare it's now going to be all the
way up to nine months and maybe even a
couple of days after or like right after
there so
northam said make the baby the baby's
delivered made comfortable and then the
mother and the doctor have a
conversation conversation is had right
that's all here's the thing i'll say
slippery slope
it's not a fallacy no and it never was
nope right i don't i don't think uh i
think
the idea that a slippery slope means you
it implies that you go off the rails
things go out of control sort of i view
it as
degrees incrementalization yeah it's not
a fallacy it's it's literally just
once the door is opened on say
two people can get married it's none of
your business then the question is under
that logic however you realize that like
an adult father could marry his daughter
right do you are you okay with that i
think that's kind of over the line and
then they can say okay but that one no
it's like hold on
if your argument is based on the idea
that two consenting adults
in in the privacy of their own home and
however they want to deal with their
lives should not be infringed upon then
why would that not open the door to
every other circumstance so how do we
put on the brakes right well that's the
thing because initially like i think if
two men want to get married they should
be free to do that right i don't think
the state should inhibit
that that behavior that's my own
personal view but how do you put the
brakes on once you've done something
like that and you safeguard or protect
them that it doesn't go off there's no
brakes yeah i don't think there are keep
your kids off the internet
my friend is a twenty one hundred
percent keep your feet off the internet
maybe not twenty four seven but pump the
brakes and supe you know supervise if
they're gonna be there imagine imagine
letting your kid watch like skinamax or
like it it's unthinkable yeah but these
days parents are like i don't know i
don't think that i don't think they're
even worse than cinemax ever was i don't
think the gay marriage thing directly
resulted in the grooming of the kids it
seems like it's like a global
weird thing no no not an american ideal
it's uh it's it's simple an internet
when the christian right said if we have
gay marriage the next thing they're
gonna do is start teaching kids about it
in school and they said that's
ridiculous if two people are privately
living their lives it's it's their
business but of course the logical
outcome is
well kids need to be taught about yes
legal precedent and about adults and how
they live right okay it should be in
school well yeah why we don't need
government schools well 100 but also on
top of that it's like how could you ever
possibly make the argument that society
is going to adopt a new value and not
pass that value onto its children
right that's what society does with its
values that's like so it's the point and
sort of like oh no yeah we'll legalize
gay marriage but like we're not going to
start telling kids about it we're not
going to start teaching kids about being
gay et cetera that's just a ridiculous
position i don't know how anyone argued
that with a straight so i think one of
the the next uh possible changes
is
the end of gender gender segregation
yeah because under the same arguments
made i was reading about the civil
rights stuff um and the arguments they
made about the end of racial segregation
and the funny thing is
and i'll say this is the argument the
left makes the same arguments made about
gender segregation were made for racial
segregation people were arguing that
black and white people were
fundamentally like very different that
you know black people had this thing
about them or what this thing so it
makes sense to separate this is the
argument again i'm saying presented by
the left as to why they should end
gender segregation they said under the
1964 civil rights act that says you
can't uh discriminate in public
accommodation they end segregation but
why do we still have gender-based
segregation in that case bleak so i
think that's the point it's not a
slippery slope it's literally moral
logic follows so what do you do with gay
kids right so when i was a child you
know i have a gay brother you know we're
kids we're looking at the series
magazine and i'm flipping to the girls
section and he's like flipping to the
guys section and we didn't know what sex
was right so who talks to them about
that right who you know without that
being considered your parents grooming
right like parents your parents decide
how to address it and that's right but i
mean
you know if they don't have parents
right if there's if there's no third
party right that's like the moral
legitimate you know person who is
supposed to be doing that whose
responsibility is it to explain why this
child is feeling the feelings that
they're feeling that may not be the same
as the rest of the kids in their class
how where do they where does some third
party have a moral right to have a
conversation with that child about what
they're feeling if nobody else does they
have no parents they have a guardian
right right well there you go okay so
they're just the guardian the guardian
yeah could they be accused of you know
grooming if they don't have the proper
relationship i don't
well
um if if you are not the the guardian or
parent of a child and then you're trying
to introduce adult sexual concepts to
them yeah i take issue with that because
i don't trust it well and also like it
is absolutely the case that parents or
guardians can and do groom children
right but right now but but i think we
can say as a blanketed case people who
are not the parent or guardian should
not under any circumstances be having
these conversations with children no
there's a circumstance in which the
parents agree that they want an educator
or someone to talk to their kids about
it so you know my attitude with the
florida bill is
some of these conversations are alright
inappropriate for kids yeah if the
parents decide my child is old enough to
start learning about these things the
parent decide what's best for their kids
if that means they have a third party
educator i disagree with it but that's
their decision and how they're raising
their kids so they can take them to a
drag queen story hour at the public
library if they want to or maybe a
private library if they want well the
issue the issue i take with drag queen
story hour is that drag is a sexualized
performance and and that's literal
grooming so let me ask you this in
response do you think a parent should
should bring their kids to go go dancer
story hours no not a drag queen i don't
think that's exactly right i don't think
they should take a drag queen story hour
but i mean there is some kind of a line
there where what you're saying is you
know if if the parent wants to teach the
child about it let's say the child is
gay you know they want to have a
conversation with them about it and they
say that the boy wants to dress up like
a woman what is a safe environment that
a parent can introduce them to those
concepts that wouldn't become grooming
if drag is inherently sexual right well
i mean but i mean like it's a community
right the gay community is a community
and there's got to be some kind of a
safe way for parents to be able to you
know if a child is asking them to
educate them i mean what do you do lock
them away in the tower and rapunzel it
down the hair when they're 18 and all of
a sudden they can be introduced to that
community or they're going to go online
and they're going to be introduced to
that community in a way that might be
damaging to them might be more harmful
to them if they can't be introduced away
i don't know and i'm not advocating for
drag queen story hours i'll tell you
that we don't know i'll tell you what's
a healthy way to do this i don't know
the answer i i agree with your with with
with uh uh the the premise
you know kids who are lgbt
need a safe environment to to talk about
and learn about these things but i will
also say that as someone uh you know my
family owned a cafe in north halsted in
chicago which is boys town
yeah it's a gay community and everything
was overtly sexual the the store fronts
were sexualized the products they sold
were were sexualized macaroni and cheese
and on display in the window was was was
genitals uh the mannequins were
anatomically correct and performing acts
on each other so this is that's not a
safe place to bring a kid you're right
and my brother and i've been having this
conversation just like in the last few
weeks about he is sick and tired of of
drag queens becoming the avatars for the
gay community like why is it that pride
has to be this sexualized event why
can't it be something that can include
conservative gays why is it and it is
and you know and uh
it's it's it's notorious at pride events
people walk around naked
uh women topless and all these things i
would not call that a safe environment
for a child to learn about these things
correct so when you have drag for
instance you have a lot of people left
saying it's just it's just dress-up it's
costume it's like okay what is a drag
performance a person in a sexualized way
uh acts provocatively and it's
accentuating sexual features and accepts
money either in the thong or in in their
and they rip their clothes off
they had desmond is amazing a little boy
ripping his clothes off on stage for
tips
that is the same thing as stripping
and they acknowledge this that drag
shows incorporate the crowd giving money
to the performer as they do these things
so
you say drag i say go go dancing or
stripping i don't see it any different
inappropriate for kids there's a new
twitter account called gays against
grooming that's right ariel scarcella
good good oh i didn't know that was her
okay yeah but she's involved but for
every reaction there's going to be an
equal counter reaction there's going to
be conservative gays who are going to
come out and are going to say this and
you know people like that should be able
to have a seat at the table at the texas
gop i know that's been a big question
lately so if we don't encourage the
conservative gays
to speak out in their that community and
offer them some kind of a moral support
then they're going to continue to be
drowned out by those people who will
sexualize children so how we do that is
it is a challenge because if you're a
conservative you know many people in the
movement are not going to be in favor of
interacting with the gay community at
all this is again the state of texas
republican party is having this big
fight right now over whether or not log
cabin republicans will be included right
so we need to have allies in that
community in order to have inroads with
that community if you really want to
protect kids that's going to have to be
a front a battlefront that we're going
to have to participate in i disagree on
that one so
i think that as soon as and you were
sort of talking about the slippery slope
earlier and societies are going to pass
their values on they're going to pass
their values onto their children and
also when you start breaking down taboos
it's not as if the people who want to
break down taboos are ever satisfied
they just keep pushing for the next
thing and i think that's sort of always
been the agenda behind the sexual
revolution going back to kinsey
and john money who i've talked about
extensively on the show and what their
goals were and they quite literally said
and this is kinsey who is the the called
the godfather of the sexual revolution
he is the person who is credited as
being the founder of the modern study of
sex or sexology and he openly said that
he thinks the only uh perversion that
exists is chastity in his book he he was
um complicit in the sexual abuse of
children and published data tables in
his literature which basically were
obtained through the sexual abuse of
children i won't get into detail on
exactly what it was uh just because it's
graphic and disgusting but the agenda of
this sexual revolution has always been
to break down all the cultural taboos
and that's not to say that every single
person participating or every single
person who is having sex outside of
marriage or engaging in homosexual
activity wants the movement to reach
that final end but that is its purpose
and we've given it a tremendous amount
of momentum as a society so i don't
think the solution to that is for the
conservative movement which needs to
stand up to it to say we need to
incorporate more behaviors which are
just non-traditional sexual activities
that we historically viewed as
perversions into our own fold to help us
make our power but conservatism is a
blanket term and it's or it's an
umbrella term that will incorporate many
different philosophies national defense
conservatism social cons it's not just
about social conservatism so there's
also but there's also fiscal
conservatives right so we're going to
have to find some kind of a balance
between these three forces homosexual
conservatives are going to be a
prominent force in advancing a
conservative agenda in the lgbt
community and it's going to happen if we
don't connect to that i think we lose a
you know big advocacy group i don't
believe in tokenism
but the most effect many of the most
effective conservative leaders are our
black conservative leaders right so we
need to be making inroads to those
communities there would have been people
probably back in the civil rights area
who have said no we don't want those
people in our groups i think it's very
different that's very different you
think it's different but no i know it's
different but a tactical or a
strategically tactical but
level it is i i don't appreciate the
insinuation that i would be in league
with people who'd want to exclude black
folks from the concern i'm not saying
okay okay okay
so my point here
and i hear what you're saying first of
all i agree with you that the
conservative movement it has become a
massive umbrella incorporates a lot of
people we were talking about this on the
show the other day you have progressives
who make up at most and i'm talking true
progressives really pushing this stuff
make up at most
four percent of the population within
western developed countries like they
are a very tiny minority ideologically
speaking well gender is 28 every fair
enough but i'm speaking overall
population numbers and then everyone
else is conservative now that obviously
doesn't work right and so i think it
makes sense to draw certain lines and
say well you know like in our
municipality or in our township to us
conservative means we promote
conservative values with respect to
human sexuality
careful about moral extremism especially
okay economy gets bad people get
desperate 1928 1929 hitler comes to
power he's a moral extremist he told you
what was pure what was good what was
right so i think when it comes to gay
people
being gay is fine but being addicted to
sex is not fine i don't care what
orientation you are it doesn't matter
what clothing you wear that's not about
being gay or being straight you can wear
whatever you want doesn't matter it's
irrelevant it doesn't matter what body
you think you exist it doesn't matter if
you're gay you're gay that's it just
don't be addicted to sex that's where it
starts to get dirty but seamus can i ask
you then are you saying then that you sh
we should exclude in the conservative
movement homosexual conservatives in
order to not promote homosexuality so i
think we should not promote
homosexuality i would not say that like
this person should not be able to speak
on this particular issue but i would say
the conservative movement should not be
using like it is conservative to support
gay marriage or homosexual do you
believe homosexuality is a choice and
not an intrinsic value i believe acting
on homosexual desires is a choice but
that the desire itself is some kind of
an intrinsic
like genetic part of that person's
makeup it may or may not be okay but i
mean the pot you leave open the
possibility that it is it's not a choice
well no i i leave open the possibility
that the attraction is not something
that the person chooses you said genetic
i would put you yeah
that's that's that's complicated
possible there could be uh uh socially
developed or
genetic
i i think that the the broader point is
simply did a person one day decide to do
it or has it something that they've they
felt grow within them what makes yeah
someone i just want to mention this too
i think
it's not so much that question i mean
there are a lot of behaviors that i
think there's a genetic predisposition
for that i would consider good or bad
without reference to that genetic
process position i'll mention so
actually i think that it could be good
i'm just saying that there
nobody's gonna make this argument but i
would say that there's a chance that
homosexuality is a good thing and the
reason why is the possibility that
evolution has created this as a an
adaptation in order to adapt for
overpopulation and the possibility the
reason why there are so many homosexuals
in large population centers is because
it is possible that it that
natural selection is creating a scenario
where it's turning off homosexual
relationships in order to account for
overpopulation
it just seems like that well i mean it's
like frogs do this right so for example
if there are you know frogs if there
aren't enough female frogs in certain
areas then they will spontaneously
change their sex so that they can
actually produce and this is a natural
process of evolution we don't know this
and i'm just postulating this right
there's not a lot of hard science on
this one but i think we will probably
find out that there is a
biological reason for why homosexuality
exists and it might be a good thing for
the survival of the modern the modern
left disagrees with you they believe
that it's a choice right so uh it used
to be that the the left in this country
thought it wasn't and uh at least it was
it was claimed the right thought it was
that people were choosing to make these
decisions i think sheamus puts it more
clearly that the decision to act on it
was is the choice yeah and now now the
weirdest thing is
among your moderate or traditional
liberal they'll still argue it's not a
choice but among the the furthest left
of gender ideology it's outright a
choice i just i wonder what makes
someone gay is it wanting to have sex
with someone of the of the same sex and
never doing it or is it having sex with
people of the same sex and not wanting
to at all
so just sort of to your point
i don't see evidence for that i mean you
acknowledge that there's no hard
evidence on it for me the question is
not what is the cause of this it's the
question of do i view this as something
worthy of promoting is this something
conservatives should be promoting right
that's
a separate issue but there's a simple
answer here i mean
uh milo yiannopoulos i guess he's
straight now is that his thing so he
calls himself reformed um
i think i understand what sheamus is
saying
someone who is conservative and lgbt or
whatever
you don't need to promote lgbt but they
can speak on conservative issues that
you agree on or that are conservative so
there's a space for them
i'd imagine right
yeah is it that you well in the same way
that i mean so i've spoken with people
who i'll give you an example um
i know people who i mean i know so many
people who do things that i would
consider to be immoral that i don't
agree with but i'm not saying that that
person should have no say on other
issues where we can work together what i
am saying is that on that particular
issue
because we don't agree we should not be
agreeing i think we're going to miss out
on a big strategic opportunity here i
think it was just two weeks ago when the
the wulk left started attacking
the white homosexuals in their movement
trying to push the white home saying
that many of the problems of the lgbt
community were these white homosexuals
who were rebelling against the push for
you know the ugly new you know
transgender flag that includes all those
things right and so what's going to
happen is that with the left eating
themselves they're going to start
pushing out many of their own people in
that group it's just too large a group
to be able to hold all these people of
many disparate views so strategically
what's happening right now i see is a
window is opening up for us to take
advantage of to bring these kinds of
people into the group not just targeting
you know white homosexuals but the
people that they're going to start
eating that they're going to go after
and say well these people are
problematic now because it's these white
homosexuals that are uh you know against
these kinds of racial policies that
we've answered crt for example right so
as that happens we should be taking
advantage of that in order to build
conservative libertarian coalition to
win elections and crush the left so you
mentioned that this community is is too
large to have all these disparate views
and that's how i feel about the
conservative community i think it's
absolutely the case that the left is
going to eat itself they're going to
force people out of their movement for
whatever reason they're always
struggling through their various wars
and revolutions to become more
ideologically pure what i'm saying is
conservatism has basically meant
something uh throughout the eras
it's basically meant we want to conserve
tradition and ultimately we want to
conserve the family but what does it
mean to be a conservative in the united
kingdom if you're concerned about the
united kingdom then you want to conserve
the things that the united states i
don't think there's a very strong source
we're not talking about we're not
talking about the united kingdom but
conservatives is not available
right conservative but if it is it's
many different types of cakes right that
cake is immutable that the properties of
that cake will remain the same such as
the arts which which is what you're
arguing for no what i'm arguing for is
that if we want our movement to be
successful in stopping the left these
kinds of compromises don't help and i
don't think the conservative movement
should be promoting a homosexual
lifestyle that's what i'm saying when
you say lifestyle is it just the love
between two men or is it the sex it's so
good it's a good question we've talked
about this before but our society uses
the word love in many different ways
whereas the ancients had different words
to describe it i do not believe that
homosexual behavior with respect to what
is done behind closed doors we'll use
euphemisms here because we're on youtube
in front of a live audience i don't
believe that those are loving acts i
don't i'm not saying that i don't think
that a gay person can love someone else
or care about them i'm saying that i
believe those acts are intrinsically
immoral you see like erotic love you're
talking about one of the eight types of
greek love is er eroticism but i
wouldn't but i don't because the thing
is i don't think erotic love is
necessarily wrong it gets into a quest
it gets into a very different question
of what's different about men and women
why is the sexual embrace between men
and women within the confines of
marriage a good thing what is different
about that or an imitation of that when
it occurs between two men and so it's a
much larger discussion but my main point
is that it's not something i believe the
conservatives if jesus christ can wash
the feet of sex workers then i think you
could get along with conservative
homosexuals but he called them to
repentance
i think the answer is the question's
already been answered momentous
a gay conservative can come in and talk
about all the conservative values in the
world if sheamus has believed being gay
is one of them then they wouldn't be
talking about but there's some of the
matter there's some value between men
and women that's for a man and a woman
to have a conversation and to find a
connection in love of some way not
necessarily erotic that's valuable even
for someone that's gay like some people
maybe aren't comfortable with people of
the opposite sex so they they do what
they're comfortable with and it's in
that way it's good for people to learn
how to communicate with someone of the
opposite sex this is this is an
interesting uh i think this is a good
conversation still because if the door
is being opened based on the statements
made by thomas
and i i think it's something to talk
about but i will say i ultimately don't
know if it matters because i'll ask you
will
is there a potential court case that
could arise that would actually
challenge obergefell
i mean it well
you can always have some sort of court
case right like
a state a state could pass a law that
would ban gay marriage right and then
somebody could challenge that law and
then it could work its way up through
the court sort of because that's kind of
what happened with abortion right
abortion was there was a federal rule
saying you can't be an abortion
pre-viability so a state just did it and
then used that to challenge it um that
said i mean
will it win no i mean it's as i said i
think that you that would lose a one um
as a pragmatic thing who's the one
right base thomas um but i think you
know i mean
i i don't know i'm a i'm a pr given that
i'm a pragmatist right like
you know whatever the actual like
contours of what it looks like for the
conservative movement to promote or not
promote or accept or not accept it's
like
well we're not you know the gay marriage
issue is base effectively tabled because
you know we're not in it at least in the
short term so
like maybe let's win political power
right now i don't know
but i mean isn't that really what we're
saying here is that you know in
embracing homosexual conservatives that
we are adding to our ranks and growing
ourselves in political power yeah i i
mean i i basically think that i mean and
i'm i probably i mean i disagree with
shameless on a lot right like i feel
like you were like this is intrinsically
immoral i'm like well i wanted to ask
you like okay that probably comes from
your catholic beliefs i would assume i
would say it's a natural opposition i
don't think someone has to be catholic
to hold it i i i guess i could see that
i just think like you know from
you know when i look at something like
that i'm like well i don't think it's
interesting yeah you know but the thing
is my point is
we don't have to agree on everything we
i don't have to agree with everything on
someone we're working with if someone
has homosexual tendencies or
inclinations i'm not saying they can't
do any good for us i am saying we're
talking about promoting yeah right
again guys we get it
there's i also do not understand your
argument we got to separate
the if the statement is there are gay
conservatives they exist what are
conservative values one two and three a
b and c conservatives who are gay and
conservative straight agree on a b and c
then there's literally no discussion
conservatism national defense
conservatives so if you're a fiscal
conservative and you meet another fiscal
conservative who happens to be gay that
wouldn't be a part of your conflict but
a homosexual conservative can all who is
in favor of gay marriage is in favor of
a socially conservative value wanting to
have gay marriage is a conservative
value that is a homosexual
conservative a homosexual because a
marriage
between two people is a conservative
value marriage itself is a conservative
institution if two men want to get
married that is showing that these
homosexuals are embracing socially
conservative values in my view
i i just don't i don't i don't you got a
separate religious marriage and legal
marriage let me let me ask will a
question you mentioned um
you don't see it as intrinsically
immoral right yeah no what about uh
two brothers who are legally adults is
that immoral or a brother and a sister
yeah no i actually that would be yeah i
think so too so so
why
uh
and again you know i'm not asking this
because i disagree with him i agree i
think it's immoral i'm curious what your
basis is for why you would say a gay
relationship is
fine but an incestuous gay relationship
or an incestuous relationship is not
okay i mean i like i've read sort of the
arguments and so the answer is actually
gonna be fairly simple like it really is
my own intuitive moral response
right
like i have an intuitive like you know
discussed reflex towards incest uh i
think that's people most people yeah do
same people feel the same way for for
gay relationships right and so so it's a
so this is the question i was bringing
up when it came to what um
what uh clarence thomas was bringing up
with this due process question is that
if you're going to argue that two
legally consenting adults can engage in
whatever behaviors they want to how
would that preclude a father and a
daughter as long as they're adults or
brothers or sisters or brother and
sister personally i think those are
wrong it's it's interesting incest is
illegal out of places and because it
would not be okay with that well isn't
it because the possible third party that
you would be introducing into the world
would be one that of stunted growth
right you're literally committing a
crime by creating like one under
something yeah then what if they use
perfect protection right exactly
gay couples don't have kids either a
brother and a sister could adopt if they
love each other so so there's there's a
there's a question here the way i view
when it comes to the slippery slope is
um i've long evolved on the idea that
one thing
goes out of control it's simply degrees
if you make a moral argument and you win
the moral argument the more argument
stands for all facets of it if you say
two consenting adults are allowed to
live in the privacy of their home and do
whatever they want it's like okay but
you realize that extends morally
logically beyond just two adult men or
to adult women it extends to a father
and a daughter a mother and a son
brothers sisters and and everything in
between and they're actually making
those arguments now and so this is the
issue i was bringing up with gender
segregation racial segregation i think
is wrong um
gender segregation i don't much have a
problem with like
a men's room in a women's room i get it
but there's a similar moral argument if
you cannot discriminate on the basis of
these intrinsic characteristics in
public accommodation why would you be
allowed to for one and not the other and
i'm like how do you answer that question
other than just saying we have a
personal moral line and that's it if
that's the case and you're saying that
it's just within you you have an
intrinsic morality then all that matters
is if you open the door to gay marriage
quite literally people who grew up with
it will not have that reflex for the
next degree which would be incest or
things of that nature not a slippery
slope just literally the next step in
incrementalizing towards it ultimately i
think we're we're arguing over in austin
i mean i appreciate everything you said
about the pro-life movement there are a
number of things we really agree on
i think where we really disagree is
first and foremost on the definition of
marriage i just don't believe that gay
marriage is a logical possibility given
how i define the term marriage i think
what we really don't agree on is where
the slippery slope starts right where
can we say this is the behavior we're
going to allow but like once we go past
that it's clear that we're going to
start slipping down that hill all right
well we're having it
what really matters is the law right
isn't it at first because what are we
trying to do are we trying to stop
people oh should we use the government
to actually stop people from engaging in
a what a private contract if someone has
a private contract and calls it a
marriage right are you are you saying
that that's not so i don't believe that
no yeah i don't believe that the federal
government has any power to redefine
marriage right i believe marriage i'm
not talking about government i'm talking
about a contract yeah i'm talking about
a private contract between two
individuals that they desire to call two
people marriage are you contract and say
that they're going to go whatever they
want but i don't believe that that is a
marriage i'm asking you do you believe
people write a contract you believe that
the government should
stop halt a contract between two
consenting adults that they call
marriage it depends on what they're
trying to do so i would not i don't
think the government should recognize it
as marriage if two people come together
and say you know we're going to live
together or we're going to do x y and z
why should we recognize marijuana if
that's what i was going to say i don't
think yeah
out of marriage generally i'm not saying
i don't think i think it's worse for it
to redefine it i've been involved i am
not
agreeing with that idea
presenting like making that point then
why would they um i think the issue is
marriage is deeply rooted in at least
united states in abrahamic tradition
marriages exist in other countries as
well and marriage because of the
secularization of the united states has
become a state institution which opens
up the question of what you're saying
contracts between consenting adults
sheamus takes a a traditional religious
perspective which is that marriage is
rooted in the abrahamic tradition well
that's not exactly right but wait my
because i actually don't so i believe
marriage preaches i mean marriage
pre-exists abraham right abraham was
married uh and so
i don't believe and this is the irony
actually like as catholics we part of
why we don't believe in gay marriage is
because we don't think the church can
redefine what marriage is we believe
marriage is what it has been through
history and it can't like change it from
being man and woman
but you're all wrong because it's not
based on the abrahamic religions
entirely because we just got my
beautiful wife who's in the corner here
stephanie we just got back from touring
bridal cave which is the lake of the
ozarks in missouri this is why i just
said at least in
america i also said
right yeah
i don't believe that christianity or
judaism invented marriage at all that's
not right but the native americans would
go to bridal cave and they would get
married and they'd had no contact with
abrahamic tradition so i mean marriage
is an institution it's human not one of
the government right but one of two
people
it's a contract in a sense a private
contract it doesn't need it's not a
contract that necessarily needs to be
written down so a marriage is a
relationship right it's not necessarily
you know because your god has deign to
bring you two together it's a
relationship between two people that can
evolve only them or it can involve them
and their god or a third party if you so
desire but that is an intrinsically
personal thing that's defined by them
not by government no it's not just
personal it involves broader society too
like there's a reason like when you have
a marriage there are other people there
observing yeah the truth yeah hold on
hold on didn't they used to consummate
the marriage in front of the party
actually the third person that was there
was the tribal cultures so there were
only typically three people but there's
a society i mean there's a the reason
like i say like when i'm like the state
should obviously to me be involved in
marriages and certifying them is because
um you know there's part of the benefit
of having the state involved is it's
very hard to make binding commitments in
our world oh
hold on the state involvement has
actually in my opinion made it so that
there is no binding involved right the
idea if they made it too you know they
made it too easy to divorce sure they
made it too easy to divorce and the
enforcement of taking resources from one
party to another it's just created a
disaster
maybe like that sort of you know kind of
easy like economic punishment makes it
too simple and maybe you need
you know you obviously obviously the
broader societal pressure and societal
stigma against divorce and things like
that and working in conjunction cultural
and enforced and was it enforced
monogamy yeah i would imagine in the
trial people mad at jordan peters when
he said that the native american tribes
if you were to start doing your buddy's
wife after you got married the tribe
would throw you out of the trial yeah so
yeah it's like banishment it's important
to know who's who you do having children
yeah yeah yeah cancel also i want to
clear something up when i said enforced
monogamy i was saying that every insult
should be given a woman who's forced
that's what i was arguing and it's like
these people try to take me out of
context and say i was setting up a
societal precedent for people to say
it's like no i was saying we should
redistribute women
it's like why is it that only the top 1
of the chads get 99
between religious marriage and legal
marriage and they use the same word
marriage but they're different
completely different definitions so we
got to stop conflating those
that i feel like you're bent on men and
women man and man can't get married
because of the religious well it's just
the def i mean not the religious aspect
because i believe marriage predates
religion it's just it's what i believe
the the term means
well marriage is
a separate question the weird thing to
me about uh we also have the supreme
court ruling on maine and the private
schools is that to the to the liberal in
this country the separation of church
and state means the state
refusing to provide for or or to
actively discriminate against religion
whereas on the right the separation of
church and state is the state cannot
discriminate on the basis of your
religion which is which is particularly
interesting so
i'm thinking back to um the famous prop
8 musical with jack black
and he said his arguments for why there
should be gay marriages the nation was
built on a separation of church and
state and then i'm like wouldn't that
actually be an argument for civil unions
a government contract and not
any kind of like ceremonial procedure
isn't that what you want well i mean in
a sense that
right like i mean i think i i i'm sort
of indifferent to whatever the state
calls the like sort of
you know certification i mean it's you
know my dad always joked that you know
my dad's a california conservative but
he joked he's like yeah sure i
absolutely want the gays to have
marriage and alimony and divorce
payments and child support payments and
everything that goes along with it um
the i think i mean i guess and i don't
know if i i'm fine with gay marriage you
know in terms of the state certifying
legal marriages i think it's like oh
there's liberal over here yeah i mean
you got me right like my most
conservative thing was i thought you
know hey conservatives should win that's
like that was my big conservative belief
now i can all argue that's crazy you
know
right remember when people were saying
no we should just like david french no
we should not win because reasons well
look what they're doing now
i hate to do a hard derail but i don't
want to just stand subject for too long
so let's let's jump to gun control
because um
the house has passed gun control package
sending at joe biden's desk after
mcconnell and other republicans defy
trump and vote for the bill no um let me
let me tell you
they did not defy trump they defied the
will of their voter base yes and i will
not forget shelley moore capito in west
virginia what you did because you are a
scumbag i am rightly pissed off about
this second most trump supporting state
in the country
and she's not for reelection for four
years so she thinks she can get away
with this that she can she can spit on
her constituents as if west virginians
want gun control well thank god for
missouri because in missouri we have the
second amendment preservation act and
this is a law
that was passed two years ago signed by
the governor mike parson that
effectively
punishes missouri police officers
and their institution whichever one that
they are a part of with a 50 000 fine if
missouri police officers are to act in
coordination with federal officers
enforcing federal laws if they are not
against the law in missouri so if you
breaking missouri law then the police
officers can participate but in missouri
if uh if joe biden passes a gun control
package and it's not in missouri's law
then missouri police officers are not
allowed to participate and still can but
not the missouri police we also have
from governor.nh.gov
hb1178 signed into law an act
prohibiting the state from enforcing any
federal statute regulation or
presidential executive order that
restricts or regulates the right of the
people to keep in and bear arms
so this so the state
cannot
the feds can come in but not the states
i mean i think i know how relevant that
is sorry
i think
my understanding of the federal law
is that it provides funding and support
to states in implementing their own red
flag laws am i am i mistaken well this
is this is not about it's not about red
flags this is about this is about the
nfa this is about any restriction on any
gun that's not codified in new hampshire
it's it's not nullification but it's
something similar in a sense right like
like we want i mean well there's there's
things like that happen in context
outside of gun where the state's like
we're not going to help the feds it's
common about sanctuary sort of like
sanctuary states i mean the feds can't
force the state to spend their money and
resources enforcing federal law right
right and that's so that's that's what
it would be um so you're not stopping
the feds from coming in obviously but if
they do come in your police officers are
totally unable to help bless unless they
want to if they want to perform a
federal raid for bump stocks then
missouri police officers are not allowed
to participate and the police don't like
it and it actually has put conservatives
in missouri in a really difficult
position because typically they would de
facto support police
and so now police are you know in a
situation where they have to try and
convince conservative lawmakers to try
and repeal or gut a law that the
lawmakers just passed overwhelmingly
that was popular and it's now a big
campaign issue in missouri i don't know
that new hampshire has any kind of an
enforcement clause
but
there's a current senate candidate named
eric greitens who's running in missouri
he was governor there for a short time
he's now running again to be in the u.s
senate and he actually came on my
program in missouri and said that he
supported the police that this amounts
to a defunding of the police he was
actually using leftist rhetoric mom's
demand rhetoric going against the second
amendment preservation act because of
the 50 000 fine that goes to those
police departments well i guess it does
amount to a de facto defunding in police
but because missouri conservatives are
more inclined to support gun gun rights
than they are to support the police
it puts republicans in a really
difficult spot i think it's actually a
beautiful thing to do i hope more states
copy us no i hear you and i just want to
mention if anyone had any illusions that
the police will not enforce gun control
laws or come take your guns because
they're conservatives this clearly
demonstrates that they will uh is it the
kind of thing where if two cops in a cop
car come and do it that it's 100 grand
like 50 000 twice them and the partner
per incident right so if you have if
there's a gun raid and the fbi is asking
for local law enforcement to help
participate which happens all the time
because usually it's really it's
actually about money because what they
want to do is civil asset forfeiture
because we have this thing called
equitable sharing and the process is
that they come in they do a raid the
states the state takes some of the money
the feds take some of the money they
split the proceeds and then they walk
out happy but the state police officers
are mad because if they aren't breaking
a missouri state law they can't
participate with the feds and they can't
share in the spoils of war right so
that's really the issue is the the
question of how much money that these
police departments are losing and and
that's why i think it's a critical issue
because it places
conservative values against the law and
when conservatives are asked whether or
not they're going to support the police
or to support gun rights
the rights are what's more important
than the cultural we support police you
know rah-rah-rah kind of a thing right
so i think it's a rubber hits the road
issue for anybody running for political
office ask them about missouri staple
law ask them about what new hampshire is
doing here and i wonder you know from a
constitutional question
what do you think will of the question
of the real deal the real nullification
which we had a crisis of which we had a
civil war
notification is nonsense sorry well go
ahead yeah tell me about i mean that was
we that was settled in the 1860s can you
define what it is oh notification is the
right of a state to defy or uh over
somehow overturn federal law in its
jurisdiction
right and so the feds would not be able
in notification we would the police
officers would actually prevent the feds
from enforcing their rights aren't they
doing that in some places though
no i mean they're they're the only thing
that they've done is like they've you
know states can say basically do what
they're doing here which is like we will
not help you right like not not that
we're saying that your law doesn't apply
here but rather we will not help you
enforce your law like that's your
problem if you want to come in and
enforce it you have the right to do that
go for it but we're not going to help
you enforce federal law that's okay
because state and federal government are
different sovereigns right but and
that's not a disrespect of federal
sovereignty because it's still saying
the federal government has the right to
enforce its law and anywhere in the
united states um
i i mean a world where you accept
nullification is a world where uh you
know new york says that's fascinating
that you have this new rule that says we
can't stop people from you know we can't
have our concealed weapons thing you
know that's funny that you have that
second amendment but we're gonna do what
we want new york and if that means
depriving everyone of their right to
guns you have no say in it we're gonna
nullify
that that supreme court ruling like nah
right that i i think that's hold on hold
on that's what they're trying to do i
hear you i hear you and i think you're
making good arguments and i'm not
totally on one side or the other here
but i would say this i might be willing
to accept that if that meant in my state
the federal government gets zero say and
can't enforce anything if if our
legislatures decide that i should be
able to have whatever i want ultimately
what but you know ultimately the the end
state of nullification is is going back
to effectively the world the united
states and the articles of confederation
right right it is the end of
and i'm like no
actually historically that was terrible
and i don't want civil war in the united
states no but that's how we get there
right like we want to go back to a world
where we had a very weak federal
government and and i mean ultimately
that there was a very very well i got to
be honest we got a pretty strong federal
government i don't know about civil wars
out of the questions no i mean
actually you know this is probably where
i disagree with you all i think we
actually do have a very strong federal
government and i think that as a result
of that civil war is totally out of the
question but if the federal government
were to pass a law that were to ban guns
federally right and the state says no
actually we're going to nullify that
because we actually interpret the
constitution as it is clearly written
you'd be you'd be in favor of the feds
being able to enforce a law that would
ban guns federally if the state wanted
to nullify it you would be no the state
can't do that the civil war uh i mean as
like
i mean obviously i think you know the
hypothetical has a problem because the
state could go to court and say this is
fed this is unconstitutional under the
second amendment and you know we know
how that would end up now right because
the supreme court would say so but just
as a matter of principle right like i
don't think you know if on any random
litigated issue if the state disagrees
with the federal government but the you
know and they litigate you know the
federal wants government wants to impose
its all on the state the state litigates
and all the courts say no the federal
government can do this it's clearly
within federal authority i don't think
the state then just gets to defy that
under that scenario would you be in
favor of a convention of states
i mean i'd be in favor of changing
articles
federal i would be in favor of changing
federal law at that point are there no
circumstances where you think article 5
of the constitution would ever
i don't want in a revolution man
revolutions are generally bad
we are like the only revolution that has
ever stuck the landing ever like i mean
think about how bad but hold up hold on
it's 20 years of conflict and death and
fighting sticking the landing and i mean
that's as good as it gets right and
right and i think it turned out really
we're extremely lucky at the founding
fathers because you look at canada right
now and it's like but they warned us
over and over about central banks and i
mean they they were like they're more
powerful than standing armies i think
they even said at one point and then the
federal reserve got formed
yeah well i mean you're you're a
jeffersonian and i'm a hypocrite right
like this is
like they already posed a revolution on
us in 1913. now we got to take it back
yeah yeah now we have another and not
all but not all revolutions are fought
with blood and tears and and sure and
the the federal reserve was a revolution
right the progressive era was a
revolution it wasn't fought with bullets
it was fought at the ballot box and so
yeah i want a revolution i don't want
fighting in the streets here in the
united states but i want an overturning
of many of the legal precedents that
have been set then you know win some
elections and and may and win some
litigation
i'm working on that
revolution four more states for a
convention revolution means to turn
forward and it actually it's it's
constantly we're in a revolution we are
revolving and if you participate in the
revolution is up to you but it's
revolving whether you're doing it or not
30 states are controlled by republicans
legislatures and four 34 for a
convention of states well i believe i
mean if we had like we what we have now
on the supreme court in terms of a
majority with these states where we had
majority of conservative states that
were pushing for this
then would you push for an article five
or think that oh you mean if we didn't
have a majority
if we did it i mean since we have a
majority supreme conservative supreme
court i'm like let's why we don't need
to do anything crazy let's just keep
litigating yes and winning uh like i
mean think about how much how much it
must how depressing must you be if
you're a progressive right now like you
control the presidency in both houses of
congress and you're taking l after l
after l right do you and you're about to
like lose
one of those yeah do you want that in
your back pocket though do you want an
article 5 convention to stay in the
constitution and to be something that's
there you don't even want th that power
i don't want like i really do not you
know people talk about national divorce
i am like a very anti-national divorce
guy i'm actually with you on that i
think i think people are wildly
underestimating how violent bloody that
would be how impossible that would be
relative to i mean
i think one thing we think most
impossible
effectively i mean me failed english
that's something
i was like
it's not it's not 1860 the you know in
the run-up to the civil war right after
civil war was declared state armies
literally just walked into federal
armories and took all the guns
the federal government was so weak we
don't we can't even comprehend how weak
the federal government was in the run-up
to the civil war which is why the states
were able to secede in the first place
it just it's just not something that
would happen and it would be bad if it
did how strong is too strong a federal
government for you
um a federal i mean a federal government
that can't be constrained by law at all
is is too strong then you have you know
that that there's no legal recourse that
there's no you don't think that we're
there not even what do you think about
the patriarchy the federal government is
not too strong in your mind uh i mean
there are places where i think the
federal government should be weaker in
places where i think the federal
government should be stronger are you
out are you comfortable
stronger libertarian right
big tech regulation
are you a hard time are you comfortable
with the patriot act
with the patriot act i'm comfortable
with some things in the patriot act like
i think it probably gives the nsa and
like there's probably too much power and
too much espionage power in general but
but not about the new one
sorry i want to know will's talking
about the
i will also say this on the question of
revolutions right people need to realize
this
this is true of basically every
revolution that i'm familiar with right
not a giant history buff you're right
the american revolution in many ways
stuck the landing but even with the
american revolution it's not as if every
single person
who was revolting was fighting because
they wanted the kind of system that the
founding fathers ended up setting up and
we see this in every like you look at
the bolshevik revolution it's not as if
or even the french revolution it's not
as if all of those people rose up to
fight because they wanted to see the
ideology that ended up taking the place
of their current system come to fruition
they were angry they wanted to fight but
it's just a very tiny organized minority
that ends up get getting to decide what
government you have after the revolution
has won or has been won
if there is anything right now that is
making the federal government weaker
it's what the doj is doing with trump
supporters oh yeah yes
that that outright with with the
solitary confinement with the rating on
jeffrey clark with the subpoenas to gop
it is basically sending a signal to half
this country that the government is
against you
and that that means if you're if you're
someone who supported trump you believe
trump or you have you are a simple
skeptic who has questions based on uh
the texas v pennsylvania lawsuit or
things like that
you are being told your your your wants
concerns are irrelevant and you will get
no reaches of grievances and if that's
the case it's exactly what ends up
happening it's it's it's it's it is in
line with what happened in 1860
when southern states felt like their uh
what was supposed to be granted to them
in terms of the federal negotiations
between states
they weren't getting what they were they
were supposed to be granted
it's a little i think it's a little
different i mean the way the way i look
at the south is the south felt
like you know to that they were on a
track to inevitably lose complete power
okay like basically they they were on
track to be a permanent and how is that
different it's not just that it's um
one of the big issues with the fugitive
slave act yeah which is the north was
not adhering to and so you have many
southern states outright being like
so our votes are meaningless the federal
government won't enforce the the the
agreements that we have as a union then
there must not be a union and if that's
happening now with the doj going after
trump's peter navarro steve bannon
jeffrey clark going after a gop chair in
nevada filing subpoenas raiding homes
these people are going to have the exact
same sentiment i think i think i mean
the the way to resolve that is to
punish them when we take power right
like i think that that's we need we need
to kind of flip it back on them right
everybody who is involved in these doj
investigations themselves needs to come
under investigation there needs to be
like trump could have subpoenas trump
couldn't do it but then i'm thinking you
got to look at a world where desantis
and a little more sophistic legally
sophisticated uh group of people are in
charge of a republican white house like
and and
i'm just saying more vengeful like
yeah i think i think the optimism is
the the midterms are going to be really
good for republicans and then in 2024
you're gonna get
either a trump war desantis who will
take those actions but i just feel like
that's just
it's unpredictable yeah no and doj what
doj is doing now and what merrick
garland is doing at doj i mean merrick
allen should be impeached that actually
should be early on the list of things
like of what should be done for what um
for uh
various i mean there's a lot of unlawful
there's actually like some seriously
like unlawful actions failure to enforce
law yep um right failure for example
like the protests at judges justice's
houses like his decision to just
completely not enforce that in my view
that's impeachable oh yeah absolutely
did he argue that was the first
amendment right he just didn't even i
don't even think he yeah discussed it
publicly like at all i think i i think
he passively just uh
i think it was it was asked of him but
he said something
like just shrugging it off
if you're not gonna protect supreme
court justices from pro you know like
there's federal law on the books that
says people aren't allowed to protest in
front of their private homes but doesn't
the first amendment supersede that no i
mean the the precedent is that it's a
time there cannot be a first there
cannot be free speech without justice
so the exception made in terms of
protest is that courts must be free from
the influence of partisans therefore you
are you are you are right to speak but
not to influence the you are not allowed
to pressure the courts through protests
well there's a i guess the real reason
that's acceptable is it's a time place
and manner restriction right like it's
saying like you're allowed to protest
you just can't do it in front of their
private home
right and you know that that's what
those rules say and and
that's the procedural the the sort of
ideological is
if the courts aren't allowed to uh sit
down discuss and try and figure out what
justice is then free speech doesn't
exist at all well but they can i mean
they can still protest at the court
right no they can't i'm sure they can um
i'm pretty sure it actually says you
cannot attempt to
protest at a court to persuade an
officer i'm well as applied that would
certainly be unconstitutional right like
if they actually tried to that would
certainly be a first amendment violation
to say you couldn't protest i could be
wrong about that there's a difference
there's a difference of yelling at the
judge as he's driving to the court
standing outside and just yelling
outside the court while they're all
inside because if you're yelling at his
car and yelling at him when he's walking
in that's definitely pressure
let's clarify
i uh you guys talking a lot about the
civil war and the the allegory which i
see which is the states being like
you're not upholding my rights
government but i think of the the
revolutionary war and the similarities
that the taxation no taxation without
representation is what sparked it and as
they're printing trillions we've got
like 30 trillion dollars of debt that's
a tax on me and i'm not seeing that
money i got i just wanted sorry just
i want to clarify yes you cannot at a
court it says whoever with the intent of
interfering with obstructing or impeding
the administration of justice or with
the intent of influencing any judge
juror witness or court officer in the
discharge of his duty pickets or parades
in or near a building housing a court of
the united states or in or near a
building or residence occupied or used
by such judge juror witness or court
officer or with such intent uses any
sound truck or similar device or resorts
to any other demonstration in or near
any such building or residence shall be
found in this title imprisoned not more
than one year or both how do you define
near i guess it's probably
yeah i mean that actually you know
that's an interesting question because i
guess the
somehow that's got to coexist with the
first amendment right so then there's
like
i don't know this i i guess i'd have to
read up on the what the how the supreme
i know the supreme court well so
what i read was the the the reason this
came about it's 1950 was because
the the the judges are basically like
how can we actually administer justice
if people will use political attacks
against us in in the course of seeking
justice so
if you're able to protest at someone's
house or at a court to influence a judge
and alter the course of justice then
there isn't any because that means like
with brett kavanaugh
if he says i am going to side with
overturning roe v wade and they go then
we're going to go to your house and
threaten you then there's not justice
for those who had filed a petition in
the court kind of reminds me of remember
back to the tommy robinson stuff right
right i was in the uk though it was in
the uk but it's sort of similar
interviewed someone outside of court so
they arrested him well he just talked
about right private you know like
what it was declared confidential
information about court proceedings and
wow you know big brain stuff man yeah i
know i was like yeah because i wonder
how they define being near a court or
residence like is it two blocks away is
it 12 feet away is it a thousand blocks
judges interpret so the judges get to
decide for themselves if you were near
their house when they're welcome to
judicial precedence how can you rely on
nine people to decide the fate of the
country it makes no sense i see why
these people are saying defy it hold on
hold on how many federal judges are
there
oh gosh a couple thousand
not that many i don't know maybe like
about a thousand i think yeah
it's not just nine but it goes up the
chain to the nine and and they can't
hear every single case and they get to
decide what they hear or what they don't
they can be like i don't even want to
deal with it that's right that's insane
no no no i do not i do not gain that
relevant it's not insane that they can
just choose not to look at things that
they don't feel like are relevant to
them but like they're relevant to me
right well but they you know there's a
lot of reasons we might not want you
know there's a lot of reasons they
shouldn't just take every single case i
understand that they're not physically
capable listen to this anarchist guy
over here maxine waters
look they're not going to take the
graphene case i keep telling you
[Laughter]
we need ai
going to take the income taxes and
contracts milton friedman thought we
needed an ai federal reserve that he
thought the whole inflation should just
be set by an algorithm i'd be open to
that if we could observe it and make
sure it's an open source thing that
we're watching happen i think it could
be we could use it as an advisor i will
i will say this times have changed
technology has changed and we probably
could do a better job with some great
minds in building a new form of
government that being said
right now in the world it's like the
united states government the structure
of it
it's the best
i don't think there's anything better
granted over time it gets bad over time
bad things happen there's bad precedent
there's a bad lot bloats and then you're
like oh i got too much garbage
there's a lot of things they didn't
predict but the idea of a legislative
branch an executive in a judicial branch
is brilliant
the way and a bicameral system within
the legislature so it wasn't right
amazing you know quite brilliant and the
strong executive frankly like most
people underestimate the power of you
you really don't like having there's a
lot of times where you get really upset
if you have a weak executive or
because also here's the interesting
thing about like having a strong
executive is it's a counterbalance of
the legislature if you're a weak
executive generally the legislature
swallows up executive ultimately
swallows up executive power and you get
like one thing so ian it is not just
about the justices
congress gets together the house and
they go hey we got an idea these are all
the people elected to represent their
districts and we think these things
should be law then it goes to the senate
who has to agree they represent
they represent the states so the
people's representation passes a bill
the state's representation agrees with
it and then the executive branch has to
sign off on it if he doesn't you need to
veto proof majority when the president
signs off on it you now have two
branches checking that then
once it becomes law people can challenge
it in court and then there's a judicial
review of it it is actually
look man you can argue that you don't
like that nine people have these
decisions it is the best system in the
world right now one issue i've got with
the repub the house of representatives
is that if they have a monopoly on the
law making right now it's like 480 60 of
them or something get to decide what
goes to the senate now no i'm sorry i'm
sorry it's not even that it's it's like
one person it's nancy pelosi
wickedness and chuck schumer uh mike
revelle that's awful mike revell
proposed this thing when he was still
alive alaskan senator called the
national initiative which would have
created a fourth branch of government
it's the people and you get
representatives from every state or
people from every state that come
together and select one of them to
represent which you probably wouldn't
even need now with the internet and you
also now gain the ability to pass laws
into the senate we all do
it like a ballot referendum kind of a
deal i'm not sure i don't know what that
is i think it's a terrible life that
sounds like a terrible terrible i think
people are smart enough to know if
someone knows how to write a law if they
learn in school how to do it then
you shoot it down
we can't shoot it down because the
majority of people who go to the ballot
box
don't sit down and read the referendum
and know exactly everything that you
want you just passed a terrible medical
marijuana bill in missouri that created
a cartel where only five to 10 to 15
people are allowed to you know
completely control the marijuana thing
and we're about to do it again the
people who want to legalize recreational
cannabis are going to go to the polls
this fall in missouri and pass a
terrible bill that all the libertarians
in missouri are actually against because
it sets up a cartel that's the kind of
laws that you get when they're written
by and and
i'll tell you why i disagree so when you
look at wikipedia
you can't sue the individuals who write
the things because they don't write
complete sentences you can't sue
wikipedia because they're the ones who
write it even though they publish it the
fact that it's so heavily decentralized
means there's no accountability for
wrongdoing but wrongdoing
taking place due to a large crowd makes
them unaccountable so there so hold on
so here's the issue
right now in new york we had larry sharp
on he mentioned 60 of people in the
state want gun control even though it's
unconstitutional
if we introduce laws based on that you
will get majority manipulation you will
get people's rights being violated and
as michael malus puts it my rights are
not up for a vote but a bunch of really
ignorant people who are unaccountable
can all just go in and make it happen
now when it comes to representative
there's accountability because the
individual is the one representing the
group has to take accountability for
passing the law or introducing it and
the courts can come after them and they
can get voted out but what kind of
accountability do these people have
right now all these people that voted
for this like i don't see how a
corporation writing a law and handing it
to a a representative to give to the
senate is is better than giving me the
opportunity to write a law and pass it
into a job the problem is
remember checks and balances right so
here's the question if you create that
fourth branch of government what role
does the supreme court and the
legislature and the president have in
order to check what powers do they have
the same over that it's the same as if
we were just
like an extrapolation of the house of
representatives everyone becomes a
representative everyone has the
opportunity now to create honestly i
think i think the end result is the
senate would just ignore it it's
impossible right like it would be a big
making but
direct democracy doesn't work it
wouldn't be that i'm not suggesting mob
rule or anything like that it would just
create another branch of government so
we have an opportunity to participate we
do not really we pick someone to go do
it for us and it's not doesn't feel like
i'm involved
and there's 300 million of us man like
you know it can feel like that when
you're only looking at federal issues if
you get involved in your state you can
see real changes happening and i see it
get better i see it all the time when
missouri representatives have meetings
with constituents they show up they make
their voices heard and policies change
it happens all the time if you look at
the federal things move much slower so i
would ask you to say why don't you pass
something like that in a state first
like pass something like that on a state
level we already kind of do that in
missouri we have a referendum process
where people can actually change the
constitution bypassing
going around the legislature going
around the executive in missouri and
passing something by a popular direct
vote in democracy and it's a nightmare
and now our constitution in missouri is
this leviathan that becomes you know
completely unwieldy and every 10 years
we have an opportunity to rewrite the
constitution and they keep trying to do
it and we can't so what the last thing
that we want to do is give the power to
direct democracy in the united states
for anybody you know to go out and just
write a law and then place that in in
the constitution do you want like your
average joe to write a law that's going
to sit next to the second amendment and
the beautiful words of the fourth
amendment the fifth amendment like we
don't have those founding father type
people again and if they are they're
certainly not coming out of the of the
regular ranks of the people and
bypassing you know not going and running
for office any of the great people that
we have right now are running for office
and they are getting elected
very few of them that i think that
people like massey and rand paul and
others
but they're there the founder the
founders are there and they're already
in the government right the issue ian
that you're you're taking is not
it's not solved by your proposal the
issue is we have a corrupt system that
the people who get elected often are
just serving special interests and it's
untenable like a bill will come with 80
or 100 800 pages and no one reads it and
right but that should be on the internet
so everyone can read it and upload it or
downvote it like a reddit thing no
absolutely popular ones go to the senate
that's
this is a single layer issue you're
looking at a problem and saying the
solution is to give it to the people
when that's that's not the solution at
all the problem is multi-faceted nuanced
and extremely difficult to solve it is
not solved by just opening up the system
to random people
i mean that's a vague way of phrasing
what i'm talking about the national
initiative doesn't just doesn't just
give mob rule it lets people get
involved in the law making process
what we need
are representatives who are moral
principled and not it's not possible to
people get bribed and no one is possible
no one is a paragon see this is a this
is this is
the issue is the system can be fixed
i agree with that your proposal does not
address the problem it just adds another
bandit on top of the problem i don't
know i think the problem is that big
huge bills are getting into the into the
representatives hands that they don't
read and then they vote yeah problems
the problem is people don't care
the problem is they vote for nancy
pelosi in her district without thinking
twice and you want to extend more power
to those same people it will not solve
the problem term limits
no i agree with that as well term limits
[Music]
hold on hold on hold on i i gotta make
it online the the term limit thing i
i've gone back and forth but the reason
doesn't work is that special interests
will just rotate their people they say
that that happens in missouri but with
there are some negatives to it but the
the benefits are that nancy pelosi types
go away that they can't come in and
establish a little kingdom and then stay
there for 20 30 40.
but he didn't pass a single bill and i
love wrong polls
you just call him wrong
there are no term limits in the
bureaucracy and so if you have term
limits exactly like congress is sort of
your way of having some oversight of the
deep state that's not how it works
though that is that is a big part of how
it works right and and certainly if we
had term limits in a world of term
limits we just get hosed
term limits for the deep state too for
the administrators i mean that would be
a lot better that's a that's a much more
effective place to start here's here's
my here's hold on hold on here's my
proposal
in any position in which you work in
government after four years you're sent
off to an island that's it
government job four years off to the end
we have term limits we on the state
level maybe it just needs to be on the
state level but in missouri we have term
limits and you're you know if you're in
the legislature you go at a certain time
and we have lost
some good people but the majority of
people are bad and the majority people
go away and that makes it but the
problem is that you think about how much
power you're giving to the legislative
aides in that world because the
legislative age are the only people who
know the like
the law well it would help it helps in
missouri
most of the legislative aides that i
know in missouri and i live in jefferson
city and work here and they are all
many of them much more libertarian than
their bosses because they have to be
conservative in office but what i know
of the legislative aides in missouri is
that it helps us because they do like
you say accrue more power but the ones
that we have in missouri are more
libertarian so there is a um
there's a thing called super chickens
right super chickens are the hens that
dominate the the pecking order so
anybody who has chickens knows that
there's going to be one hand who's going
to be like i'm in charge and pushing
everybody around so they didn't
experiment they took a bunch of a bunch
of different flocks took the highest
ranking pecking order chickens and said
okay let's put them in a flock and see
how they handle it they all killed each
other
so i i bring that up because i'm like i
wonder what would happen
if the island id i know i'm kidding but
imagine if we took
everyone out you get four years in
office for whatever reason and
afterwards island iowa what would that
look like
you'd lose a lot of institutional memory
right like there's and there's a lot of
places i'm gonna talk about two was i'm
talking about what would an island look
like if you just like a boat comes up
and they're like off you go and they
leave well and then you enter the
society of all former politicians it
would look like arlington virginia
yeah that's a good point
also i mean will if we want
institutional memory we can always like
venture to the island and grab one of
them
how did the nuclear reactors work how
does that
what's that regulation where how does
how do you reset them i don't remember
you're like all right thank you for uh
like this is my hopefully
off the island like this is my best
friend jimmy's like holding a coconut
you're like guy he doesn't remember
part of why i think term limits is a
better idea now than it was before is
because of like social media people get
really famous and when they're in office
for four years they get you know 1.2
million followers then they're gone
they're out of they're out of politics
but they still have a huge following
they can still make a living well people
still trust there are a lot of people
people who are in politics for four
years who don't end up with 1.2 million
followers right the ones that we're
thinking of are all giant but that's
because they're giant i just got to read
one super chat real quick because i just
saw it phil go and says tim it's a bad
idea the elite already have had their
ideas
spicy now will how do we get rid of the
deep state how do you get rid of the
deep state yeah
is there like a spray or something
right here you you change civil service
laws right that's the where basically
you make people much more easy to fire
for the basis of just like you're not
you're not one of us right like
the for and i mean that creates its own
set of like corruption issues which is
like you sweep in a whole every time you
have a new administration you sweep out
a whole bunch of civil servants that you
wouldn't have swept out before but what
about their institutional knowledge we
would lose i mean you you want like
you basically it's like you want a world
where you can you know you have the
choice about whether you keep that
institutional knowledge around or not
right like you get the benefit of it if
you think these people are genuinely
nonpartisan but if you come in and
you're like oh look the fbi wants to
destroy my administration i'm going to
fire as many people as want to do that
to make it make a point like you just
need basically you want to give
more authority to the white house over
the executive branch if it wants to use
it and i think the the big problem is
when you have a white house that can't
deal with a hostile executive branch
then you have the deep state problem so
are you opposed to presidential term
limits
uh
uh
no i mean like i think
some you probably it's such an important
position that it's probably it's and
it's such a powerful position that's
probably good that you get some rotation
in there so the senate is less powerful
so
senate's less powerful senate senate's
primary function now is becoming the
primary function is becoming oversight
honestly but but wouldn't you want to
see that meme carpe dance make of the
trump 2024 2028 2032 just going on
definitely wouldn't that be great i mean
and you know like there's a trade-off
right i mean you you do get like
sometimes you really have a good
president and it's probably good that
they weren't kicked out i mean like why
think about it i mean
fdr was would have been termed out right
in the middle of world war ii was it
good
like that probably would have been a bad
thing right like are we sure
i mean he was elected in 32 for his
first term and then he was
he would his term would have ran out in
january of
1940
which i guess would have we weren't in
the war yet but we were close
and then certainly 40 but i mean she was
41. shouldn't democracy the way it's
laid out shouldn't it be like the way
that the system is set up
shouldn't it be that that transition of
power should occur in wartime and do so
in such a way so it has to be yeah i
mean we always want peaceful transfer of
power i mean the the but the question is
sort of a technocratic one is is it good
to force people out of power
you know
by a term limit via like a statute
rather than allowing the people to
continue to choose the person they like
to be continuing power i mean you know
there's no
term limits in britain for prime
ministers during wartime the power of
the presidency swells and expands right
so i mean isn't that probably the
argument for why allowing that kind of
transfer of power or protecting the
executive branch sure but like also you
know wild swings in the policy of an
administration during wartime don't seem
great you're right right like you're
right you know that there's probably a
benefit to
and also like there's probably a benefit
to
that's not saying that you couldn't
right like there's still elections the
guy still has to win office every time
but i mean we've had presidents that
have changed hands during wars sure but
we're not at the scale of world war ii
and you know we've had peaceful
transfers of power between george w bush
and barack obama right so sure so i mean
it did did it affect our wartime
capability i mean no but there's like i
guess the the you know what you're
saying is is you actually have to not
just say that it's merely not like not
bad to have switches of power you have
to like come up with like affirmatively
good like it is good thing that people
are forced to leave the presidency and
that we are forced to have these changes
at a maximum eight years and i don't
know i think it's actually a much closer
question right like you you the the
nature of our system inevitably weakens
the president at a certain point in his
like term where everybody knows he's
going to be gone soon like right you
know it's not necessarily having lame
ducks is not necessarily a good thing in
terms of how our system of government
works because you get this sort of
degrading of the executive at the end of
you know the last two years of his
tournament that's not a good thing
not necessarily no i mean just think
about like
you know what does it mean for how the
rest of the government you know the way
i see it is sovereign power is always
conserved right so if the president's
power is ebbing away that who somebody's
has it maybe it's congress maybe it's
you know unelected executive branch
officials
who knows right but it doesn't it just
doesn't seem obvious to me that it's
like a good thing
that you know we have these lame duck
periods and because other systems don't
have it like the england doesn't you
know and they have a democracy but their
prime ministers could just keep getting
real well
they have
it's not a democracy it's a it's a
parliamentary monarchy
parliamentary monarchy but the same same
kind of same concept applies where it's
like the leader does not necessarily
have to go after x number of times i
don't like democracy that's why i bring
it up when people are like our democracy
i'm like your democratic institutions in
your either parliamentary parliamentary
monarchy or constitutional republic to
point out um transfer of power during
war time we haven't actually been at war
since 1943 42 whenever we declared war
congress hasn't declared a war since so
it's just been these military actions
i play civilization and i i just can't
stand the the democratic form of
government in that game you gotta go
republic it's the way to do it that's
right let's go to super chats
if you haven't all wow i mean
you can also choose like religious
fundamentalism um well i'm talking about
civilization two by the way going back
to the 90s hard anyway damn would you
kindly smash that like button over turn
the like button oh subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and become a member at timcast.com in
the top right of the screen say that
sign up button hit that support our work
we just hired a couple more journalists
we're going to be hiring more people
we're expanding doing a lot of really
awesome stuff check out youtube.com cast
castle because we're basically making a
cultural comedy kind of uh show based on
the shenanigans that happens here at the
castle with all of our staff members and
team members really really fun and uh
with your support we're actually
expanding into documentaries we're
working on one about gun control and the
federal reserve
it's expensive to make documentaries but
we're gonna do it um when you sign up
you're gonna be helping in that mission
so that being said let's read some of
these super chats
all right
jeb reid says common sense gender laws
there were only two genders nature the
original signs decided millions of years
ago
yeah you'd mentioned gender uh was it
discrimination and how like gender
segregates gender segregation i think
it's more sexual segregation and we
should keep keep hammering that it's not
about gender it's about what sex
i'm using the traditional colloquial
definition of the word gender to mean
biologically they slid that one in
because
want to tantalize the male testosterone
with naked women it's not just that it's
well
so what i my responsibilities are
mindlessly just like can't help but
they're animals that's for sure so
[Laughter]
the reason it makes sense right is
because so when you're looking at like
civil rights laws uh with respect to
you know segregation between black
people and white people and comparing
them to gender segregation the
difference is like there are actual
fundamental
important differences between men and
women like there are differences between
the cycles that's also reflected in how
the court evaluates those rules like
it's a different level of scrutiny
pretty sure it's intermediate scrutiny
and they made the argument in the 50s
that there were biological differences
between people based on race but yeah
but the arguments weren't good right so
we had uh we had a conversation about
this and it's like if you look at a
person from you know haiti and a person
from somalia
like that it doesn't the skin color and
does not hold a commonality between
these they're very very different one's
taller one's on average shorter ones on
average thinner or whatever so the
racial arguments make no sense
across all civilizations there are
there is sexual dimorphism exactly
that's why that's the argument how do we
look at human beings in like race versus
genetics right if we look at some people
on the genetic level can you tell
genetically that someone is of a certain
race yeah there's a funny meme where it
shows two skeletons embracing
and that like someone commented like
it's so beautiful because at this point
you don't know if it's a man or a woman
or if they're white or black and it's
just love and then someone responded
like actually you can take a look at the
mandibular blah blah like this one's
clearly an asian female on the left you
can tell because of the more prominent
frontal lobe it's male and very
obviously caucasian it's like just based
on the skeleton they knew they knew the
race also i loved the argument that like
when you strip every characteristic away
from a person down to the point where
they're just a skeleton we're really all
the same
like not making a point so does that
lead to like arguments about biological
determinism and things like that
what's that exactly right well i mean
like so for example like um
sickle cell anemia right so like that
that's that's you know shared by you
know all races can have it but it's you
know confined to african americans right
and so talking about that as like a
biological determinant
does it
jump from not just like a a disease but
does it jump to behaviors or something
that could be looked at as a social
behavior is there you know some kind of
a reason for why people of certain
races behave in a certain way that's
what biological determinism would be
right you're gonna you're inherently
because of your biology going to behave
in a certain way more likely because
you're of this certain race if genetics
determine your race and you can tell
from genetics what somebody's racist in
so far as i'm just asking by the
propensity in so far as
you know
clear that up
great question i don't know so far as a
propensity towards a disease may
influence a culture's uh evolution so a
culture that's more likely to have
sickle cell anemia might behave as a
culturally different ways and and pass
on different values to their kids eat
different foods cultures that eat
different foods are going to have
different reactions to those foods um
japan for instance they like they
traditionally had like a low-fat diet
they have um i read that japanese people
have a certain gut bacteria they can
break down cellulose better and it's
because they're culturally they would
eat a lot of seaweed a lot of cellulose
um my view on this based on a lot of
what i've read is that
the the uh there there's a mix of nature
versus nurture and everything
but that
behavioral changes based on race are so
minimal and that it's typically cultural
so if you take a look at the stereotype
about like asians being smart it's like
yeah well look at their cultural values
the cultural values are the parents are
very strict on you know you should study
you should do these things i also know
stoner pothead loser asian people
because they did not have those cult
that those values i think culture
absolutely trumps in terms of behavior
right so then is that so that does that
make japanese people is that a
superpower in a sense right to be able
to like break down cellulose better than
other people right well it's a gut
bacteria something you can get that
bacteria right so you know i rise of
race i read a book where they talked
about like jewish domination of
basketball before african americans came
in right so it was like the most
uncommon thing you could ever imagine
before african americans were known to
play basketball and to be great at
basketball it was actually a bunch of
jewish basketball leagues that existed
and then all of a sudden that changed
right which would imply that you know
anybody could be good at basketball
right but i mean is it so then is it a
cultural thing that african americans
just play basketball more so they tend
to you know be better at it right or is
there a biological question it's both we
look at crispr which is this genetic
engineering i mean they're making
attempting to make super humans by
tweaking their genes there's definitely
a correlation between your genetics and
your abilities well well
i i i think i think you got to clarify
the issue with basketball is height and
if certain people from certain uh
backgrounds are taller
that's what gets you in the nba i think
i read that if you're seven feet tall
you have a 17 chance of being in the nba
because it's just like we want a tall
person they can they can reach better so
i'm not sure that the issue is your
ability so much as
people from sweden and norway tend to be
a lot taller and they're white than say
people from france who are a lot shorter
have you seen like the penis study in
sizes in different cultures or different
countries around the world all right
let's read some more let's let's get
that one all right we got mayor bear
says ben shapiro today broke down the
decision concurrence and the dissent he
explained all the legal and
constitutional parts it was extremely
informative it's worth a listen or watch
well ben is a lawyer and he's very smart
so i would be uh i would be surprised if
it wasn't
why didn't we even bring will on
your own
took care of it ben shapiro already took
care of go watch ben's no also robert's
i mean right that was it was really more
a 5'4 than a 63 obviously like robert's
concurrence was just a concurrence in
the judgment
and it was really cringe we talked about
this earlier i think how he wanted he
came he wanted to have this like
reasonable opportunity standard
um right and to replace viability
because he's like but and he's like
looking at the majority he's like you
guys are discarding precedent
willy-nilly and they look at him and
they're like you want to invent a
completely new standard that's new for
that's not started this isis either bro
sorry good old roberts all right let's
read some more we got blessed fatherhood
says love the cake shim cast the real
work starts now cherish all women we're
doing cool stuff in oklahoma love is
sometimes difficult exodus 20.
well all right beautiful patrick bank
says as an adopted person yes it needs
more support
i agree it's crazy you guys ever watched
30 rock
i love that show when uh tina fey's
character liz lemon is trying to adopt a
kid and and like the the plot of it is
that it's extremely difficult and i'm
like that's crazy there's a baby that's
in need of a family and they're like
we're
like this is a wealthy white woman in
new york city who works for nbc like how
hard is it but the gag is basically
that's very difficult to do
and then i think ultimately she doesn't
get the kid right or does she she does
get the kid i don't know whatever i
haven't seen him why
why why do they pose such a challenge
for adoption these days i don't know
much about it but i just well there's
there's good money to be made
for the state and holding the children
hostage selling them to people who want
them it's also like they they say it's
kind of like an admittance fee so if you
can't afford to pay that fee then it
shows that you're able to monetarily
take care of the child as well some
people argue for that i'm not saying we
do but if you lower the cost of adopting
a baby to zero and somebody can just
come and be like oh i'll take i'll take
10 10 babies yeah then i'll sell them
off to slavery or something got it all
right fritter says pendulums swing and
the harder you try to push the bob to
your side the harder faster and farther
it swings to the other side when you
lose your grip and you always lose your
grip
we're talking about beware the moral
superiority where none of us are perfect
all right
jason lindholm says chicago aurora
naperville and other illinois cities
having protests tim and sheamus are you
blind oh wow that's so that's so crazy
in in democrat controlled chicago
they're protesting as if anyone there is
pro-life i i don't get it there it's
it's i just don't understand
we're gonna we're gonna go protest in
riot in the city that agrees with us
it's like okay there you go well i get
it if they go to a red red city or state
then people are going to come out and be
like come back well the thing is there's
a chance obviously if it uh isn't
peaceful which by the way joe biden said
make sure your protests are peaceful so
you know good on him and then he went
like this and then he went where are we
exactly even though your administration
encouraged people to break the law and
protest outside justice's homes all
right um but what happens is in these
communities where there is a stray
conservative or conservative
organization or a church
if they get rowdy that's what they go
after that's what they attack
how is joe biden still a catholic by the
way come on he's not he's not a
practicing catholic by definition he's
just he doesn't give a sense to catholic
teaching he doesn't the goal is to trick
liberals into thinking he's catholic so
that he can make some kind of argument
but like catholics look at them like
yeah no come on he literally like he
tries to make an identity politi uh
politics argument about being catholic
because it's like no i just identify as
one i call myself one therefore i am one
even though if i like i completely
[Laughter]
you guys are joking but i mean this
would be a good show just all by itself
like the battle in between christianity
between progressive christians and
conservative christians you know you
have like this fight between that's
going on the southern baptist convention
right now between you know corrupt
pastors and things and a lot of
progressive christians out there that
are advancing the things that you don't
agree in but they're doing it in the
name of god yeah and it would be a
fascinating thing for you know somebody
who doesn't have a dog in the fight
there but who does have a dog in the
fight against progressivism to see you
know are you all on your back feet right
now i mean are you conservative
christians losing to progressive
christians because it sure seems that
way not in our churches to be honest
most of the young people i mean almost
all the young catholics i know are very
conservative very orthodox don't harbor
heretical beliefs so with joe biden i've
said this before one of the necessary
requirements in order to be considered a
practicing catholic is you have to give
full ascent to catholic teaching and joe
biden clearly doesn't on many issues
he's like no i don't believe that man
and so
he's called devout when he's not even
practicing
and if you consider yourself to be a
christian but you reject catholic
doctrines you reject the authority of
the papacy you are protesting the church
there's a word for a protest ant you're
a protestant you're a pro that is what
the word protestant means and i'm sorry
for my protestant brothers and sisters
in the audience i don't mean to force
joe biden onto you
if your church is any good he wouldn't
be considered a member there either but
joe biden is not a practicing catholic
by definition all right let's read some
more we got josh m who says i read
two-thirds of americans are pro-choice
to some degree i believe pro-life state
house reps and governors are going to
have a hard time holding their seats
i've also read gop leadership agree and
are quite worried thoughts i will
address this by saying
they're not pro-choice in the way you
think if republicans want to hold their
seats they need to make sure their
constituents know democrats tried to
pass a bill that allowed abortion at
nine months okay the people who are
pro-choice are more pro-choice probably
like me or will where it's like there's
some area of nuance but beyond this you
know elective abortion we don't like
these things when you actually break
down
all these polls what they ask these
people is are you pro-choice or pro-life
and they'll say i'm pro-choice and then
they'll say do you think there should be
restrictions on abortion in fact the
interesting thing is i think it was
gallop
actually uh the majority of people sided
with a view oh no i'm sorry i'm sorry
this is historical data we pulled up
through wikipedia
going back decades repeated
most people think there should be
legitimate reasons for an abortion which
basically bans 90 what 93 of abortions
yeah no more elective abortion that
that's like two-thirds of people think
yes abortion should be allowed with
reasons i wish they knew yeah the the
center of american public opinion is
more
pro-life than the current law right i
think that's the way to think about it
and so
it's not but it's not like absolute is
pro-life it's just it's it's definitely
it's it honestly i think the center of
american opinion is probably more like
european law where it's something like
you know you have
like you know early it's usually not
allowed past like 12 weeks without a
doctor's without a doctor's explanation
of why it's necessary and so i think so
as a result i think i don't think this
will have a big political impact in the
way that people think i actually
honestly i think this is going to be
better for republicans than it is for
democrats because my basic thesis is
this is very demoralizing if you are an
activist democrat or if you're a
moderate democrat like well yeah the
other side it's the economy
these social issues can only last so
long until someone right now they're
screaming they're like i can't believe
the supreme court would do this to us we
need to go protest they all get out and
go into their car and they're driving uh
we're not gonna be able to make it
downtown unless i stop for gas then
they're gonna pull into the gas station
and go
what are we mad about again staring at
the five dollar pump being like uh see
they're arguing that this is going to
you know galvanize the base that they're
going to make it all this these fall
elections all about abortion the left is
saying that this is going to help us win
these elections or at least stem the
tide of a republican red wave coming
this way you know think about how much
democrat politicians have failed their
constituents on this one right like if
their constituents are like no we would
really just like to preserve the right
to an abortion
uh or like preserve roe as it was well
you had the opportunity to codify it
you've had plenty of opportunity to
codify it into federal law when they had
like you know think of obama area when
they had the super majority they want
the wedge issue uh they had the
opportunity to like get rbg to retire
during obama's term like i mean there's
so many well let's
just read some more super chats we got
um the isaac glover show says tim you're
wrong about recalling senators the first
amendment gives us the right to petition
the government for a redress of
grievances check the definition of
petition again and you'll realize you
can't recall anybody well look the
government is comprised of people and
people can do what they want if they
have confidence in what they're doing
but uh maybe i am wrong can you recall a
senator no
okay well there you go can a state
legislature we call a senator no
so how do you deal with senators who are
acting in defiance of the of their
constituents uh expulsion
right how do you do that uh
senate can expel its own members oh okay
so that's never gonna happen yeah no
that's the only has it's i thought it
has happened it has happened it happened
after the civil war what if there was
some kind of fourth branch of government
where the people could put could put to
put forth uh bills or whatever that's a
good
idea so they could expel other wouldn't
it be funny if ian start arguing against
it and we're trying to convince him he's
like stupid stop now
they're never working we'd be better off
just letting like california secede and
then reconquering it and administering
it as a territory so you do believe in a
great divorce hey can we add any new
states you know maybe annex alberta you
think that the united states will ever
add like a 51st state i think that's a
wonderful idea
absolutely next album texas was was
given the option to be five states ah
did you know that that's interesting
when they joined the union and they did
they opted to remain as texas so imagine
what that would look like can the 51st
state not be d.c
no dc should never be able to dc should
never be if anything just shouldn't be
there expand dc to include arlington
yeah that was a historical mistake to
let virgin arlington come to virginia we
need to disenfranchise more liberals
[Laughter]
virginia from northern virginia here
that media matters
anyone saying dc should be a state in my
opinion is ignorant or evil dc is a
federal territory for obvious reason no
state should have power over the federal
government that's the point but here's
the problem taxation and representation
right ian
are they being represented probably
they're not supposed to live there okay
so that's your goal is i don't live in
dc if you want representation yes okay
listen i mean if i'm not saying that dc
was brought into maryland the maryland
state government could pressure the
federal government and get favors and
that is not going to work for a union it
would cause dissolution abolish housing
in the district of columbia i'm just a
practical man again
is there a way to disenfranchise more
liberals
like well look i'm not saying
i'm not saying
all the victims
takes are still so calm he's like i'm
not saying we can evict everybody from
washington d.c but the fact is it was a
mistake to start bringing housing into
the federal territory that was also
administered government
all right let's grab some more
jean
dumas says i think japan has it right
they acknowledge that the nuclear family
is important many of the lgbt activists
and the one that make the woke gospel
want to destroy the nuclear family
bml used to advertise on the blm used to
advertise that on their web page they're
not the only one that's true and they
got rid of it because people were
freaking out
blm was very much anti-family that's
right
brodie may says please see if bryce gray
will come on the show he's an amazing
musician and his newest song drag queens
is great titles such as maga boy and gun
toten patriot he's been doing culture
jamming since 2016. i i've heard of him
didn't he do a song that mentioned me
him and um
yeah it was him patriot jay maybe no no
no no no no no
i'm i'm i feel bad for his name i think
somebody did mention you i don't
remember yeah that he did a song with
someone
him and this other guy did a song and
they mentioned something like temple
anomaly anomaly that's what it was yeah
that was cool we shouted them out
very cool
all right and and and i'll tell you if
you like tastefully make fun of me in a
song like i'll shout it out you know
what i mean
you know like like hassan is hassan
[ __ ] is tweeting at me told me i should
be aborted i said hassan be nice jeez
yeah
that's really that's awful well it's
because i i posted this ridiculous tweet
where i said if if hillary clinton would
have won in 2016
uh scotus would have mandated forced
abortions today like the point was the
extreme opposite of what happened like
as if that would really happen so then
he said you should be a mandated
abortion i thought tim's always
explaining his twitter he's like look
this is like not what i meant this was a
joke
because the people who are listening are
in on it no i know you know what i mean
so i want to like i'm like hey he's like
here's the point of doing it i'm just
posting nonsense to you know
like make a point
all right let's grab some more what do
we got here super chat super chats
all right
barely insane says in terms of marriage
i think the government should allow
civil unions that participate in the
same benefits gay or not marriage is a
religious deal and should only be
handled by churches and synagogues etc
well that the issue is in the in the uh
like traditional american
view it is but you mentioned native
americans have it you know marriage
exists average oh yeah ancient pagan
stuff but they would have concubines as
well it was just different type of
marriage like i said abraham was was
married marriage far pre-exists abraham
all right
jedi mine trick says tim's tim's staff
enough
uh tim staff enough though i've been a
member since 2019 and went out of my way
to be cool told me to go f myself when i
had a billing issue changes my
perspective totally i don't believe you
good sir ah doubt i i yeah very serious
doubt wow yeah can i just shout
something out that this is not a super
chat but it's in the chat someone said
ian and sheamus should start wearing
beanies
[Laughter]
if you would like to get a christian
perspective on origins morality and what
the bible actually says check out steve
greg at the narrowpath.com no
denominations no cults just a life lived
in christ interesting
all right
jrc is a covenant versus a contract it's
pretty simple to understand the
difference as long as you have morals
and values
what is the difference
i guess he's saying like covenant isn't
breakable or a covenant is something you
take an oath with a religious content
maybe
uh i don't i mean i again i i see the
value of like making commitments that
you can't
wiggle out of right like it just seems
marriage there like one obvious really
pragmatic benefit of marriage
being in it is like the knowledge that
you can't just leave
right and that that forces you to work
things out and compromise and like work
with each other and not whole you know
especially once you have children like
not hold the dissolution of the marriage
over each other's heads
um like i see i see relationships where
you know people have children but aren't
married and i'm just like you're so
unlucky like you really you both would
be so much better off if you were you
know had just this massive social
pressure forcing you to stay together
and had undertaken this commitment to
each other that's that no fault divorce
yeah no i'm not i'm not for it i'm i'm i
think problem yep all right let's read
some more we got jacob who says tim i am
unapologetically pro-life and i have my
sister's baby shower tomorrow there will
be dozens of liberal women there and the
roe v wade news will undoubtedly
undoubtedly be a big subject subject of
discussion sheamus pray for me
absolutely yes absolutely i would just
put it this way
my attitude is always
sort of passive curiosity
and so
don't get heated don't get angry just
like not along and be like oh okay and
then ask questions and one of them is
but you know like the democrats tried
passing that bill that would allow for
ending the baby's life
even if the baby could be delivered i
don't understand that and then if they
get mad and say no i'm like i don't know
like yeah that's that's the bill like i
don't know that and just like don't
argue with them but just be like why are
you getting so mad like i don't
understand why yourself this is a baby
shower and it's kind of like look it's a
baby we're here because we wanted to
have a baby well you can do the opposite
you can be like should have aborted it
oh yeah keep the focus of the day on the
baby and the health of the baby yeah and
the gloriousness of birth refuse to get
a gift and be like i disagree uh i'm i'm
pro roe v wade so that baby should have
been aborted i'm an anti-natalist how
dare you bring another life into this
world i've got one of those ideologies
that only exists on reddit yeah it's
just so weird when i'm talking with
people like so you're a natalist and i'm
like a natalie you mean i'm a normal
person yes but i'm like i'm not even
arguing any strong conservation i was
just like
we shouldn't kill babies at nine months
they're not like natalist i'm like i
just like i hate when people come up
with new terms for normal
that's completely like
just i mean i don't want to say that
because i think it's bad to say it on
this show because youtube will but but
you realize like the fundamental
underlying tension like with the
anti-natalist position like you're alive
yeah
right like but i mean there are people
who wish they aren't there are people
who have been on camera who have said i
wish i was aborted that's so weird those
are the kind of people that are like i'm
moving to canada if trump gets elected
and then they don't go if you there are
methods to right and i don't really want
constitutional amendment
if you tweet that you're leaving the
country due to a presidential election
not only do you are you obligated to do
so under our new constitutional
amendment but we will tax pair fund it
yeah we'll subsidize it that's fine
yeah i just i i absolutely do not
advocate suicide i think it is a grave
and horrible evil do not do it but when
someone who is alive says like i hate
being alive or like i wish i was never
born it's like well clearly you find
some goodness and value in life because
you're still here why would you not want
to extend that to other human beings
well i'll tell you this i have been told
by multiple people who are christian
that they wish they were dead because
they want to be in heaven
well i mean i i hope to be with that i
would tell them don't presume right
brutal yeah i mean
that's right that's right there's no
rush either all right will p says tim
bring austin peterson back on irl as
soon as possible this was the best show
yeah it is a good show
this was good by the way we all
disagreed on so much this was like
always good remember when will defended
the federal reserve i know every time
someone made a strong statement one
person was like yes someone was like no
i made the mistake of seeing the chats
on there and it's like get austin out of
here
i was like i gotta turn that off well
when will when i brought up that will
defend the federal reserve all of the
ones oh yeah like no no
all the ap that's what makes it fun oh
well did all those ones were there too
many ones did that cause inflation there
were 20.
worth less
yeah but like if you don't i'm i'm not
i'm not going to get started and ruin
your game wait wait are you for the are
you for the inflation algorithm the
milton friedman thing is that okay know
about the the i don't know about the
algorithm but i definitely don't want a
gold standard it's a terrible ad i'm not
saying gold standard i don't talk about
free banking it's scottish free banking
in the late 1800s where there was there
was a gold standard but the banks
printed their own money do you want that
bill i mean
free banking free banking google it
google it free banking
free banking sir google it i don't know
man yes there you go the gilded age yes
thank you kill today exactly
the liberals call it the age of robber
barons but we call it the gilded age
where one of the greatest american
presidents grover cleveland presided
over administrations a time of
unprecedented prosperity and wealth of
the the tail end of the industrial
revolution in the united states when we
were building up our industrial
manufacturing and turning the united
states into a powerhouse that became
what it was today the gilded age had a
banking system that was uh called a free
banking system based on a scottish
banking system that existed during a
period of the 1700s this is the adam
smith system this is a system where
banks are allowed to print and create
their own currencies for those are just
listening austin is holding up the bank
of columbus 10 bill it is a
decentralized but it is it is legal
tender you just knew that bank backed
the value of that currency you don't
need a federal reserve for it can i ask
how much did you pay for that
uh that thing was like 75 bucks all
right 75 bucks maybe isn't it that's
appreciation yeah i was gonna say that's
appreciation but clearly there's a good
investment if you had a bunch if you
held on to that right but you wanted to
make it way less actually right
you want money to have a stable value
the question is is what is money and can
government determine the value of money
right money money wasn't a creation of
government money predates government we
traded amongst ourselves
currency
oh no no no
some maniacal economist at the head of
the federal reserve can determine how
much our money values what was the
inception of currency it must have been
four or five thousand bc if not
so
if you want to know about where currency
came from just google john money i want
you all to learn about him that's right
look up john monty learn everything
about him and everything he invented and
where it all came from i love those i
love those memes where they do that
where it'll be like if you're ever
wondering why the banks are ripping you
off you need to understand how the bank
banking power came to be just google
searched john money to understand yeah
the best the best one i ever saw was
gage grosskrois was the father of five
children he was burdened or he was you
know attacked look him up and find out
all about him okay i'm just gonna say
one more time look up free banking yeah
look everybody so i will say this part
of the problem with that is most people
do not look up what the meme tells them
to look up they just believe the meme is
true
all right all right we'll just uh let's
grab a couple more super chats here
all right let's see we got
colton sullock says hey tim and crew i
keep hearing the argument about roe v
wade being overturned would make birth
control harder to get not sure how but
could you all explain
yeah
the i mean it's the substantive due
process argument that we already went
over the idea that it would undermine
substantive due process
uh the doctrine and thereby undermine
the cases like i think the griswold case
is the
contraception case
um but as i explained earlier
very unlikely that it actually is in the
job's opinion that is expressly
disclaimed that it has any impact on
these other substantive due process
cases and so
not gonna happen right that was um
griswald right yeah griswold v
connecticut yeah that was the right to
contraception
well interesting
all right let's see we'll try and grab
one more
thousand foot deep end says sheamus
phenomenal appearance on pop culture
crisis today you had this protestant
fist pumping your calling of the law of
the lost to repentance and hope in
christ hope to see you back on soon
thank you so much see what i'm doing to
your shows tim hey yeah make it more
valuable stocks rising thank you that's
right all right ladies and gentlemen if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button
over turn the like button subscribe to
this channel share the show if you like
it become a member at timcast.com to
support the work we're doing as we
expand this operation you can follow the
show at timcast irl you can follow me at
timcast everywhere follow me on
instagram uh austin do you want to shout
anything out yeah ap for liberty on
twitter facebook and instagram and i
just launched a new store where i
actually 3d print
buddhas with thomas jefferson's head on
them and george washington's head on so
check that out it's ap for liberty
gorilla though yes yeah this is a
gorilla see i was so excited to go i
brought
i brought all my buddhas and 3d prints
for you guys but i was so excited to
come on that i left them at the hotel so
hopefully next time but check it out at
ap for liberty shop.com it's just ap the
number four ap for libertyshop.com
there's also a lot of cool like fourth
of july stuff on there so go and check
it out and check out the store and buy
some merch and follow me on twitter
right on will uh at will chamberlain on
twitter um also i'm you know i should
shout out my organizations um the
internet accountability project the i
the underscore iap that's also on
twitter fighting big tech abuses
and then the article 3 project which i
don't have the twitter handle right
there but very relevant today article 3
project fought hard to get um you know
trump supreme court justices confirmed
that seems to have been a pretty good
idea and a pretty good thing to be
working on so yeah
uh i'm seamus coughlin my credentials
well someone who just chatted in
described me as semi-acceptable oh
here we are oh moving on i run a youtube
channel called freedom tunes we released
a video thursday and a video today i
think you guys are going to love it it's
about roe v wade being overturned and
how this is crazy thank you so much and
there's also a 12 minute version of it
so it's five minutes long there's a full
12 minute version of it at
freedomtunes.com if you become a member
five bucks a month you'll get an extra
cartoon every single week plus behind
the scenes content you'll be supporting
independent content so go over there and
check it out thank you so much i liked
it because sheamus says my name several
times i do actually say
that's really
so i i plugged my my shop right there
and i watched the store 26 people
instantly jumped
you guys move people way to go ap for
liberty it being for liberty yeah that's
cool um i just found some really
groundbreaking information the statue of
liberty was chained i don't know if you
guys know this the original idea of the
statue of liberty was that she had a
broken chains on her hands she's a freed
slave they the the industrialists of the
time or whoever decided no it's too
prominent put the chains at her feet if
you see the statue of liberty from above
she has broken chain at her feet i i
thought the statue of liberty was given
to us by the french so they could sneak
in while they were hidden inside
if you go there you'll meet them yeah
but it's it's to remember that we come
from freed slaves not only the british
but the our own civil war to free the
slaves before that the romans slay like
we are descended and let it never happen
again it would be beautiful if we saw
that in new york harbor for whatever
reason they made her look like an
erudite you know
post freedom but we got to remember the
actual essence of freedom i feel a very
strong connection with ian
are you like the radical crazy
libertarian here or no
he's like half the time radical
authorities i don't know
two of those three words it was the
funniest the funniest time was when ian
went on about like how he believes in
the death penalty and it was like i
can't remember which guest we had but
they were like arguing with you but then
you agreed on the death penalty he's
like wow
i got i don't know where to box but i
can't box myself into it but what's
right what looks
sensical what it looks you know dmt
tripping
oh i'm totally into psychedelics maybe
that's where you're feeling that's what
it is
have you smoked before it's the
mushrooms i think they're sipped on
ayahuasca it's nice you got a dmt rush
i'll go deeper on it later
anyway i am also here in the corner i
pushed all the buttons this evening it
was a lot of work because they were all
talking over each other which was very
fun very engaged conversation thank you
guys both very much for coming austin
for coming from all the way from
missouri which kind of sounds like
paradise right now
will for coming from dc i'm happy we
were able to get you out of there for a
few hours you guys may follow me on
twitter and mines.com at sourpatchlids
we're also going to the mines event in
new york city very excited to be there i
want a selfie with tulsi gabbard stay
tuned we'll see if i get that you guys
can follow me at sourpatchlist.me as
well
check out cast castle on youtube for our
silly comedy vlogs you can check out
youtube.com chicken city if you want to
watch chickens they're sleeping right
now but you can watch them thanks for
hanging out everybody and we'll see you
all next time
you